what we have here are 25 minutes of
mostly uninterrupted cyberpunk 2077
gameplay
before we get started if you don't want
any early game spoilers i recommend
clicking out now
with that out of the way these first
three scenes show snippets from
each life path you can pick at the
beginning of the game this first one we
are going to take a look at is from the
street kid path
in this scenario v was born in night
city and is in the middle of hijacking a
car when an
unfriendly jackie wells shows up your
moment to shine kiddo
good luck
let's take this piece of wonder tech for
a whirl
you're a man of little faith see
we're rich now fire her up and call me
when you're underway
tell you where to go
hmm looks like this will be a cool
breeze
get the [ __ ] out
okay easy
nothing personal gopa just biz
rayfield's mine what man never heard of
thieves honor
finders keepers i was first listen
only one or two ways to do this friendly
or [ __ ] up either way the ending's the
same
i'm taking the car what what are you
doing
drop your weapons
you're under arrest
and i can see him nice and slow
jackie wells my old pal from the hood
see you haven't grown an ounce wiser hey
detective stance been a while huh
inspectors
same [ __ ]
speaking of your mug's familiar too
yeah you seen to me
left for atlanta looking for a slice of
happiness
guess you didn't find it i've always
maintained it's the same for all you
termites in haywood born here
live here die here looks like i was
right
you know [ __ ] all about me
truth hurts huh just watch your tone
i'm not a patient man come on stance
give us a break huh you lock us up
that just took off till trial and then
what
worst case we get some months
you know standing room only nowadays in
alberta
so i'd probably be out early
ah the easter thieves 4430 street trash
got him in custody mr fujioka we'll be
taking them now
it's a waste of effort i have no time to
testify or play it under investigation
suggesting we let him go sir i suggest
you toss them in the sea
cuffed legs broken so this trash doesn't
float
you hurt him [ __ ]
next up we have the nomad life path and
this setup v
is trying to smuggle something into
night city with the help of jackie
we have two sections from this
introduction v repairing a car
envy and jackie speeding across the
border into night city with border
control hot on their tail
you said it was nothing serious when i
came in you said you were sure
guess i was wrong can always look for
another shop where they won't ask a low
nomad why he's hugging the border
that's fine step aside what
got any idea what to do
i'm gonna bypass the coupling and rig a
hot water
compressor run on and on good season
did anyone ask your opinion
[Applause]
okay let's see what happens
it's like i was telling you
not shabby at all questions how long
it'll last you
man it'll get me to night city i figure
something else out there
antenna on this heap don't seem like it
packs a punch not liable to hear much
[Applause]
hey mike didn't know you had a customer
uh rolled in a few hours passed i
i thought he at least called in don't
you swear to mine
we're gonna hash it out
don't you know you owe the sheriff a
word when you pay his town a visit
to tell him what's brought you here
maybe even over a cup of coffee
no need to worry i won't be staying long
didn't answer my question now did you
you're gonna tell me what happened back
there
let's say i have a bad feeling about
this oh
happened a lot to you rarely
smelling trouble around the bend drive
jackie just drive
someone's coming our way this does not
look good
stop your vehicle immediately let's get
out of here on
it you are transporting contraband that
is corporate property
i repeat stop the car
[Music]
foreign
gotta keep moving
finally we have the corpo life path and
this scene v is a successful corpo
meeting an old friend named one jackie
wells
[Music]
no designated landing site has been
detected at the destination
find a spot close to the bar as close as
you can
[ __ ] procedures initiating landing
sequence based on new parameters
[Music]
we have arrived at your destination
[ __ ] your problem psycho suit this
look like a landing pad to you
could have [ __ ] crushed us
we ain't looking for no beef with you
seems trouble once in
keep an eye on the av for me will you
i don't get paid to do that i wasn't
asking
i'm not a scratch on it when i get back
welcome to lizzie's
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
now come here often do you it's good to
[Applause]
now sit down and tell me what's got your
shorts in a knot
it's good to see you too jack how you
been
moving away from the opening setups this
section will show you the ins and outs
of brain dance or bd
a virtual reality tech that lets v
examine past events
in gritty detail and remember everything
on full blast they'll spot us extra for
a wicked adrenaline okay
on you go
down everybody on the ground i want to
see you kissing the flooring
money now or i will [ __ ] drop you i
swear to god
well yeah hey now before i blow your
[ __ ] head off
ah
slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well that was
too much felt
could feel the guy's pain his
dress his hope
hope wrapped up in something else
probably took a booster just before
you'll be fine
got everything set up let's switch over
to editing mode
i'll sever the link to the bd roller's
sensory array
you'll be able to look around freely all
scenes yours
full cam control and analysis mode so
move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up with think of it as your own little
sandbox
so analysis mode you control playback
can even pause when you feel the need
then you use the editor console to
unpause try it
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go
in snatch the cash get out and we sell
the pd to those psycho freaks from the
studio
got it got it dream as hell right well
that's not all
you can speed things up or rewind
whatever you like
give it a try rewind roll it back to the
top
okay you can also reset the recording
that'll take you right back to the
beginning
try it
now for some fun this here's why you
came in the first place
in analysis mode you get to view and
even scan
details of the enviro recorded by the bd
roller
focus on the heat the gun this gunk gets
from his buddy at the beginning
now scan it
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in
snatch the cash get up excellent
okay right here
excellent let's move on
now heads up in analysis mode you can
ferret out background noise and
conversations if the roller got close
enough
this tech records everything every
little detail
even the sights and sounds the roller
was never aware of
to see the sources of the recorded
sensory signals switch to the audio
layer in the editor
go ahead and try that now okay good
now you should see several sound
signatures in the store
choose one and hone in on it
pack a six case of broseph and a couple
of zappers
okay we have a deal today on two flavors
cuddy everybody so
any thoughts unbelievable seriously
like what's happening right next to me
yeah it's how bd recording implants work
they pick up everything all the elements
in the background
then an editor tweaks them makes them
pop keep playing with the sound
explore it a bit we'll move on when you
get bored
when i see you kissing the flooring
money method
sometimes you can analyze extra layers
in the raw stuff the rollers cyberware
picked up
like what eb's got kiroshi optics that
grab
infrared meaning you should be able to
grab heat signatures from her recording
hello nice scanning works on peeps too
walk up to the wounded chick try
scanning her
alright next thing scroll forward to the
part where our artist gets a lead
injection
where i will [ __ ] drop you i swear to
god
[ __ ] head off
see that they shot him and he never saw
it coming
but you will here it comes my favorite
part of the game
see the blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam
must have caught our shooter you'll see
in a sec
cam feeds to the screen behind the clerk
roll back to where the screens in the
kids field of vision
then scan it
his own chumba shot him probably plan to
all along must have got a nice slice of
cred on the black market for a bd like
this
bd freaks are ready to pay a prime for a
real flatline
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit
yeah it's impressive right it's too bad
most of the bds we do here are only good
for flogging the log
next up is a bit of combat
it's just a matter of time [ __ ]
hey she's there
please take [ __ ] steak
so this
ah
do not do this the implantation is
against my police
please i do not want them
calm down it's over now i'm not with
them
now here's a bit of hand-to-hand combat
with a pair of interesting characters
i know where i'm gonna strike before i
do it
typical knew i'd say that you're for a
fight
which one of you is my guy me
wasn't expecting the tag team but
whatever i guess
so who do i got first no no
you don't get it that body and this one
i'm the same person
so what i'm seeing double
i used to be twins which you could
probably guess
the twins had a close bond they wanted
to be closer
stronger so they installed neural
oscillation sticks
and now they're well me
one person two bodies
my bodies do everything together
everything
fine but we're raising the stakes
fair see no problem with that so
can we get started show me what you got
[Music]
[Music]
and last but not least here's v and
jackie blowing off steam in a nightclub
called
afterlife
no
yeah about time holmes
what's new with senora wells
uh you know she's worried about me
whatever can't help herself you know
checking to see if i'm not riding in
some dumpster like most of the whales
boys
it's really starting to wear on me more
i tell her everything's okay
more i feel like i'm straight up lying
but that's done after tomorrow
afterlife here we come baby
yeah we're only here because dex is
pulling the strings
doubt that puts us in the same league as
them
oh but we are they just don't know it
yet
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
place used to be a morgue you believe
that
who would have thunk i know right
way before our time that but proper
burials were still a thing
and who might you clowns be
name's v this is jackie wells
oh is that supposed to sound familiar
it will soon we're here to see dex
yo dex got two live ones saying they're
here to see you
yeah all right then
says he needs a second or two go get
yourselves drinks or something
way ahead of you
this is it
the heart of night city let's see right
there
beating hear it can you imagine
susan forest boa boa maybe even morgan
blackhand
all sat on those stools fell asleep on
that same
bar looks like we're up
hey you see that old lady there
that's rogue best fixer in all of night
city
thought dex was the best
rogue was lining up jobs when dex was
still [ __ ] in diapers
the place belongs to her what can i get
you
you order two tequila
fashions with a splash of cerveza and a
chili garnish
duo of johnny silverhands coming up
right on chica
somebody did their homework looks like
the dog ate mine
age old tradition drinks are named after
our regulars
say i wanted a drink named after me what
would i have to do
snuff it mind-blowingly spectacular
fashion
it up and be best what a beautiful
tradition
tonight city and the afterlife
[Music]
9 30 this evening
you made it you blowing up all over the
news are you alone
i just want the money you got the chip
all right start her up bug
why don't you go to the bathroom wash up
we going to be with you in a minute
wow come on man your neck it's a mess
while hot security has yet to comment we
do know the suspect seems to have plenty
initiating combat mode go destination
confirmed
that's what i'm talking about all right
in and out
[ __ ] we're rich oh we are going to
the major leagues jeremy
jack oh [ __ ]
hey hey just think about all the good
[ __ ] we're gonna have huh
oh sorry
[Music]
foreign
just take the [ __ ] chip decks
every corporal cop in this city is gonna
be blasting down these doors
after what you and your psycho friend
did
we didn't need all this cock-sucking
attention dammit
[Music]
wake the [ __ ] up samurai
we have a city to burn
i love this town the city of endless
opportunity
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
city like any other it's bigger
no no not just any other city legends
are born here
the major leagues we're only here
because dex is pulling the strings
doubt that puts us in the same league as
them but we are
they just don't know it yet but if you
got the gohanis
and you know how to use them you could
do damn near anything
unless you catch a bull even then you go
out with a bang right
you know you can make heaps more eddie's
motivational speaker
yo mr v a pleasure so what's the gate
dicks you meant to come out in one piece
[Music]
how about we go over the plan there's
this
prototype check a biochip to be precise
jobs could grab it guessing it belongs
to a court
arasaka robbing some heavy hitters
thought you could blackmail me
[ __ ] how risks have a war first rule
of the afterlife
baby goes without saying we do this on
the hush
ideally no bodies not a one
sounds simple enough these lead [ __ ]
is it gonna be dangerous don't you worry
miami we're bulletproof
get your ass moving now what the [ __ ]
just happened in there i can't stop
digging night city
[ __ ] major leagues happy now jackie
yeah
that's [ __ ] high i'm the bail oh my
god we're so [ __ ]
and you who are you
[ __ ]
i wouldn't write these lyrics for myself
[Music]
so it's kind of interesting to to get
into like the mindset of
who is this character and what would
they write about what what's their
agenda
[Music]
it's interesting to to try to like catch
a language that
that's his and try to catch a language
that's like
a part of this game
[Applause]
there's a reason why we're here
[Music]
it was purple maybe who was a fan of the
band
he knew refused and he knew my voice and
he's oh that's a perfect voice for
for johnny
and that they wanted i guess a sound
that was a bit contemporary from when
it's
when johnny's supposed to have had the
band because he's sort of like an
anti-establishment kind of guy gonna
drag a corporal rat on stage
make him kneel down with gaston light
them up so of course there are things
that you can relate to and like
just like this outcast and this rebel
that's fighting against like the the
corporates and
that's definitely something that's been
a part of my life and a part of the
fuselage
we came out of the punk rock scene of
northern sweden
he's like the future version of us
[Music]
so i i think it makes sense i think it
totally makes sense for us
to be here making these songs about him
or for him
so it's pretty cool
yeah no no no no no but
yeah but like white vibrato
[Music]
and then let me just sort of feel i mean
yeah slowly
we don't have a different mode than just
going
all in so we really work on these songs
trying to make them
as good as possible then they're not
actually
our songs it's interesting as as a
musician
to play another musician because that's
essentially what we're doing i mean
we're not here
as refused we're here samurai and i'm
here with johnny
it's still around you know so it's like
the voice we're representing here is
someone else
it's been a mind [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
get down
[Music]
i mean the shouting in itself is just
like second nature to me because i've
been i've been doing this for a very
long time
but then when someone comes in and says
i'm happy with everything except for as
a limb
again it's as a as a
i think we had it earlier okay
the shouting is great but think of that
accent or think of that like enunciation
it's a bit weird because it is it's a
very different way of singing when you
when you're screaming like that and it's
hard to sort of
keep swallowing some syllables there
adjust your accent
oh yeah just try it again so it's it's
been a bit
frustrating it wasn't it wasn't
[Music]
it wasn't horrible but it wasn't great
but i mean i get it i mean we we have to
maintain the illusion that
this character that's a character of the
game also is
me like when i'm singing it so it makes
sense but yeah it's it's a bit
different to have someone telling you
exactly how to
announce these things because i'm not
used to usually people are just like
give me a thumbs up and then like you
know you you think the things like the
rhythm and you think about the pitch and
you think about all these things but
then someone comes in and like
that word sounded weird i'm like what no
it's how i sing but
so it's been a very uh yeah very
painful at times
it's all right see it is soon i'm
chipping
in roll the boots out chip in here
build that connection
it's a very interesting thing to be part
of as as a person that's not a gamer
i don't think i fully understand the
impact that this might have
if people like these songs and if people
are excited
then that's gonna be great i mean we are
spending a lot of time
trying to get this right trying to get
it to sound like you know
like samurai would sound you know so
it's it's quite interesting it's a very
different way of
of making music actually
johnny silverhand is the zac de la rocha
of the cyberpunk universe a
musician with a radical
anti-establishment message
johnny's a disgruntled veteran of the
1990s central american conflict an
anarchist
and most importantly the first rocker
boy here's the origins and rise to fame
of one of cyberpunk's most prolific
characters
[Music]
a rockerboy is a class wholly unique to
creator mike pondsmith cyberpunk
universe
rocker boys and gals are charismatic
public figures
who speak up against the powers that be
they usually come in the form of
musicians like johnny silverhand but
they don't have to shred the guitar or
play an instrument to be considered a
rocker boy according to pondsmith
himself to be a rockerboy you just need
to be able to
eloquently stick it to the man and
convince your buds to stick it to the
man
with you man but rocketboy doesn't have
to be a musician a rocker boy
can be anyone who's a orator of the
people
anybody who can talk to others
and convince them by the power of words
music sometimes art and so forth
although johnny silverhand is a 100 year
old rock legend in cyberpunk 2077 his
story begins in the 1990s during the
central american conflict a bloody
struggle launched by the united states
war machine to squash communism
unsurprisingly the united states had
ulterior motives there were important
resources at play that the united states
government wanted a piece of
while the us did a good job of keeping
this a secret from the general
population
soldiers began to uncover the
government's underhanded intentions
many enlisted soldiers broken and
battered at this point deserted and
returned to the united states
among these deserters was one robert
john under after losing an arm he
returned to night city with a red-hot
rebellious spark in his eyes
after getting fitted with a new arasaka
designed cybernetic arm he changed his
name
to johnny silverhand and formed a band
called samurai the group consisted of
carrie eurodyne
denny best isis formerly known as nancy
and henry
you know good old henry samurai's music
was a global phenomenon
the world knew who johnny silverhand was
and they heard his messages of rebellion
and revolution
loud and clear samurai criticized
government world leaders and of course
the mega corporations that ruled the
world
more importantly samurai's music lit a
fire under the general public
everyday folks were picking up
instruments and getting their message
out there
and so the rocker boy was born
unfortunately samurai came to an abrupt
end when nancy pushed her abusive
boyfriend out of a window
and killed him i say good for nancy but
the united states justice system
seemed to disagree and put her behind
bars shortly after samurai separated
johnny silverhand kicked off his solo
career his first solo release was titled
sins of your brothers
if his work with samurai consisted of
vague lessons in rebellion
sins of your brothers overtly called out
the injustices of the central american
conflict
johnny's first solo album proved to be a
massive hit
not only did it sell like crazy but it
changed the world's perception of the
central american conflict and shined a
light on the united states imperialistic
practices
things were going well for johnny his
fame was on the rise and he started
seeing a woman named altyria
cunningham or alt for short alt an
incredibly talented netrunner created a
program called soulkiller that
essentially rips a netrunner's mind from
their skull and makes a copy of it
inside a mainframe the body still alive
is left to decay the good times
sputtered to a halt when arasaka thugs
kidnapped alt to get a hold of her soul
killer program
johnny in a fit of rage devised a plan
to rescue alt from the arasaka building
with the help of thompson
a famous journalist with a distaste for
mega corpse it's important to note that
at this point
johnny hates arasaka he already did to
some extent but now things
are personal i imagine he'll make his
hatred of arasaka
very clear in cyberpunk 2077
i'm sure he also hates that shiny metal
arasaka arm he's rocking
with the help of his former bandmates
johnny silverhand puts on a free show
near the arasaka building to hopefully
incite a riot
then johnny would lead an assault on
arasaka to save alt
just like when rage against the machine
performed at the democratic national
convention in 2000
a riot erupted outside of the arasaka
building after samurai played a song
titled chip and
in fun fact swedish hardcore band
refused did an official rendition of
this song which you can listen to right
now
as well as a few other samurai songs
[Applause]
johnny's crew with a crowd of 6 000
broke into arasaka headquarters
sadly they were too late alt was dead
and her mind was trapped in a mainframe
this particular section comes from a
story titled never fade away in the
cyberpunk 2020 rulebook we will most
likely visit this event in another video
but if you want a more in-depth look at
this key moment in johnny's life we
recommend reading the full story
after that johnny disappeared there were
rumors that the indomitable cyborg adam
smasher put a bullet in johnny but his
remains were never found
of course this isn't the last time we'll
hear from johnny silverhand as his
electronic ghost seems to play a
significant role in cyberpunk 2077
played by the illustrious keanu reeves
cyberpunk
there's a brief overview of johnny
silverhand's life and legacy
there's a lot more to this story but
we'll have to wait until november to
find out more
in the meantime if there's a cyberpunk
topic you'd like to see us cover leave
it in the comment sections below and
make sure to tune in next week as
jean-luc
breaks down johnny's arch-nemesis
arasaka
and with that we'll see you next time
samurai
one of the oldest and most influential
mega corporations in the world of
cyberpunk is arasaka
it has played a pivotal part in some of
the franchise's most
important stories and is said to be a
major player in cyberpunk 2077.
in many ways it's looking like arasaka's
role in the game is said to be the
culmination of characters
and plotlines the pen and paper game has
been building for decades
so before we see it play out in the
video game you need to know the history
of arasaka
who its major players are and how the
simple manufacturing company became a
trojan horse
for world domination
the now monolithic arasaka started out
as a simple japanese manufacturing
company
it was founded around the turn of the
20th century by sassai arasaka
a clever businessman with a talent for
predicting the direction the world was
going
he saw world war ii on the horizon and
positioned his company as a major
military manufacturer for japan
bringing him a lot of success sasai also
had the foresight to see that japan
would lose so arasaka began distributing
its vast wealth to overseas accounts
sparing itself from the ruin of the
japanese economy following the country's
surrender
in the years following the war arasaka
would slowly trickle those funds back
in keeping the company on top as a vital
part of japan
that's how arasaka got its start but the
history of the modern day arasaka begins
with sasai's son
saburo saburo arasaka was a renowned
pilot during world war
ii he was fiercely nationalistic
strongly believing that japan should
take its rightful place as leader of the
world
japan's surrender at the end of world
war ii was a huge blow for
saburo who contemplated suicide but like
his father he had the vision and
foresight to think ahead
saburo saw the global economic path the
world was taking
and knew that while japan had failed
militarily it could succeed commercially
thanks to his father's actions arasaka
continued to thrive
and accrue a massive fortune after the
war so
saburo prepared and waited until his
father's death in 1960
when he assumed control of arasaka it
was then time for saburo to start the
long game
his end goal to bring back japan to
imperial glory
and become a political and economic
superpower that controlled the world
saburo's first step was to create and
expand the arasaka bank
the bank acted as the reliable backbone
of the company
always providing good income thanks to
smart business decisions on saburo's end
this allowed arasaka the freedom to
invest in other ventures
such as the arasaka security division
which provided the highest standards of
electronic security
as well as physical manpower like armed
guards
by the 1990s arasaka security was the
most powerful and respected security
company
in the world with thousands of
businesses using their services
and then the collapse happened ever the
forward thinker saburo saw the economic
crash coming and
made preparations as well as a few
manipulations
in order to profit from the destruction
of modern society
arasaka came out of the collapse as one
of the largest corporations in the world
and it was time for saburo's master plan
to take shape
arasaka's security would create one of
the first corporate armies
saburo would go on a spree buying out
valuable businesses with arasaka bank in
one hand
and eviscerating the competition with
his personal army with the other
by 2020 the mantle of ceo pastor
saburo's eldest son k
arasaka but in many ways k was just a
figurehead and the true power in
decision making
still lay with a 101 year old sabura
his mind was still as sharp as ever and
his goal of complete world domination
was ever present
the only thing keeping him from
achieving it was alliances made by other
corporations
in the interest of keeping arasaka in
check one such corporation was militech
an american arms manufacturer and
military contractor
militech was arasaka's biggest
competitor and this rivalry would end up
being the source
of arasaka's first major defeat
what would later be known as the fourth
corporate war started in 2021
as a simple rivalry between cino and
otec which were fighting over the assets
of the recently bankrupt ihag
looking to gain the upper hand both
turned to the backing of large megacorps
for military resources
otech went with militech and ceno went
with arasaka
the two megacorps had been at each
other's throats for years
and this was the perfect excuse they had
been looking for to begin a proxy war
where they could battle it out
and like many proxy wars it stopped
being about a dispute over a bankrupt
company's assets
in fact by 2022 ceno and otec had
settled their little war
but arasaka and militech were just
getting started and tensions quickly
escalated into a very
real war many organizations and
countries around the globe were dragged
into their conflict
including the united states and japan
both of whose economies heavily relied
on militech and arasaka respectively
things were spiraling out of control
quickly as this corporate rivalry was
setting the world
on fire eventually arasaka began losing
ground in the united states
with its final major holdout being night
city home of its american headquarters
this all led to one of the most
important moments in the world of
cyberpunk
militech sent several strike teams of
mercenaries to infiltrate arasaka tower
one of which was led by the legendary
johnny silverhand
you can learn more about why johnny was
involved in our video about him
there's a lot that happened in arasaka
tower that day enough to do a whole
video on it alone
but the most important thing is how it
ended
a thermonuclear device was detonated
resulting in the destruction of central
night city
and the deaths of over half a million
people in what would later be referred
to as the night city holocaust
the blame was placed on arasaka and u.s
president elizabeth cress used the event
to nationalize militech
and expel arasaka from the united states
small conflicts continued for two more
years
but at this point arasaka had lost ceo k
arasaka eldest son of saburo
died by suicide in 2025 officially
bringing the fourth corporate war to an
end
the fallout of the war severely damaged
arasaka
all its overseas assets had been seized
by different governments
and it was kicked out of pretty much
everywhere the japanese government which
had long butted heads with arasaka
was terrified of a potential retaliation
from other nations
despite not being directly involved but
the government still needed arasaka due
to its massive
influence on the japanese economy so the
government nationalized all of arasaka's
assets
and arasaka became a japan-only company
for the next decade with the loss of its
ceo and power
an internal power struggle took place
within arasaka
there are three major players the first
was the kiji
led by hanako arasaka the youngest
daughter of saburo
hanako is an intelligent and
kind-hearted woman who wanted to live an
independent life
rather than be a porn in her father's
corporate game which is perhaps why she
led a faction to grab the power for
herself
next there's the hato led by mishiko
arasaka the youngest daughter of the
late k
she is a u.s citizen and had the backing
of the u.s government
which wanted to take control of arasaka
the final group is the outside rebel
faction taka
led by yorenobu arasaka another of
saburo's children
yoronobu is by far the most interesting
of the three
when his father told him of the true
purpose of the arasaka corporation
yuronobu left his family in disgust he
went on to become a famous rocker boy
the johnny silverhand of japan more so
in the rebellious spirit as he was not
an actual musician
he started the steal dragons a gang he
used to attack arasaka from the shadows
yarinobu was even involved in the events
leading up to the nuclear destination of
arasaka tower
unfortunately there's not much
information on the details of this
decade-long family rivalry
however the conflict was eventually
solved and arasaka reunited under one
banner again
arasaka spent much of the next several
decades rebuilding power and regaining a
foothold outside of japan
a return to america was tricky following
its expulsion in 2023
but an opportunity presented itself for
arasaka to worm its way back in
the new united states had what was known
as the unification war in 2069
an attempt by the government to regain
control of a series of free states
that had seceded from the nation night
city had long been wary of the us after
it basically abandoned the city
following the night city holocaust
the city avoided involvement in the war
until the federal invasion of coronado
bay gave them no choice but to act city
councilman lucius rein turned to arasaka
for help
this was the opportunity arasaka was
looking for and it showed up
days later with the super carrier
causing a swift retreat
of the nusa the sudden involvement of
arasaka drummed up fears of another
fourth corporate war level crisis
and as such the new united states backed
down and signed a treaty of unification
ending the short-lived war night city
was now an independent city state
and by the present day of 2077 arasaka
was once again
in control of the city which brings us
to the upcoming video game in which
arasaka plays a pretty major role
if you pick the corporal path option
main character v
will start as an employee for arasaka's
counter intelligence division
and you'll get to see the ruthless
arasaka corporate lifestyle for yourself
the company is also involved in the
game's main plot
which involves stealing an ancient
prototype chip from arasaka
expect an appearance from saburo arasaka
himself
who is still ceo of the company at the
ripe old age of 158.
how could he possibly still be alive you
ask well let's just say
saburo had plans long ago to download
his personality into an
ai when he died the very existence of
this piece of tech has been at the heart
of many of cyberpunk's most
important stories and will be an
important part of the video game
yorinobu will also play a role in the
story he has for unknown reasons
returned to the fold of his father's
empire but knowing him he has his
own plans and motivations the events of
cyberpunk 2077 might end up being
another major chapter
in the history of arasaka we covered a
lot of information today and there are
plenty of details left for further
exploration
in fact next week jake will be diving
deeper into the fourth corporate war
so make sure to come back for that as
always let us know if there's a
particular subject in the world of
cyberpunk you want to know more about
and thanks for watching
if you've been following cyberpunk 2077
you probably know how deadly
megacorporations like militech and
arasaka can be
not only can corporal conflicts be waged
economically but many regimes are
enforced through violence
theft and arson some of these conflicts
play out in smaller arenas
a gunfight in the streets of night city
or an assassination attempt on upper
management
however if there's enough resources at
play these contained conflicts can
expand into full-blown multi-court
battles
this is what we call a corporate war
although there were three corporate wars
prior to the fourth
obviously the fourth corporate war
played a big part in shaping the
corporate
cultural and environmental landscape of
cyberpunk's universe
even though the war ended 50 years
before the events of cyberpunk 2077
remnants of the war are and always will
be present in night city
but before we dig into the fourth
corporate war let's take a look back at
the previous corporate wars
from 2004 to 2016 corporations were
involved in three distinct wars
most of these conflicts were fought by
security personnel and mercenaries with
high-tech weaponry
the first war was between epic games and
apple
i mean ebm and orbital air for control
over the remains of the failing company
transworld airlines ultimately orbital
air forced ebm to surrender and they
took control of transworld airlines
assets
although this war only lasted from 2004
to 2006 it set a dangerous precedent for
other corporations
it meant that violence and warfare were
viable tactics many corporations beefed
up their security departments when the
dust settled i say when the dust settled
but the dust from corporate warfare
didn't have much time to settle
in 2006 the second corporate war kicked
off
this time the major players were two
massive oil companies
petrochem and sovoil oil companies
engaged in deceit clandestine warfare
and underhanded tactics
that's the first time i've heard of
something like that while petrochem did
significant damage to sove oil it
ultimately lost the battle with sovoil
coming out on top but the war
wreaked havoc on the world most notably
the southern pacific rim became a
cesspool of pollution and oil
according to cyberpunk 2020 firestorm
stormfront try saying that five times
fast
the south china sea became a lifeless
chemical stew all but inhabitable today
nations and economies were destroyed in
the fallout and so voyle was forced to
pay reparations
the second corporate war was also the
first time a corporation blatantly
ignored governments and nations in order
to secure
a victory the third corporate war played
out a little differently than the last
two due to the fact that it was mostly
fought on the net this war was between
investment councillors meryl
asukaga and finch and the rothstein fund
a subsidiary of the bank of new york
manf was embezzling money from the
rothstein fund when the rothstein fund
uncovered manf's scheme
they notified the los angeles district
attorney's office manf retaliated by
launching a netrunner assault on the
rothstein fund
a few months later manf left the corpses
of two rothstein execs on the da's
doorsteps
the rostein fund dissolved shortly after
the worst was yet to come for night city
in 2021 a german nautical tech company
by the name of
in inter international handles marine
act or ihag for short came into some
financial trouble
two competing nautical companies caught
wind of ihack's financial downturn and
both attempted to swoop in
and take control of the sinking pun
intended nautical corp
those companies were ocean technology
and energy corporation
otech for short and a french company i'm
not going to try to pronounce
which we'll call ceno for short ihag
otech and ceno had been ruthless
competitors for years vying for economic
dominance in marine biotechnology when
ihack filed for bankruptcy
otec encino opened bids to acquire the
company unfortunately before a c no
negotiator could present a buyout
offered to ihag she was kidnapped
i wonder who or what could have been
behind that
wasting no time at all otec signed a
protection security contract with
militech
a huge tech and weapons corporation that
had been in competition with arasaka for
years
of course this caused cino to partner up
with arasaka the japanese-based
mega-corporation
this more or less kicked off a proxy war
between militech and arasaka
officially both corps are trying to sway
the outcome of the ihag takeover
unofficially the two major corporations
found a reason to launch a clandestine
conflict known as the shadow war
most of the attacks during this period
consisted of assassination
theft and net raids between arasaka and
militech the shadow raids didn't last
long though as the covert operations of
both companies came to a head
war broke loose known as the hot war
many corpse and security specialists
picked aside and fighting broke out in
all major cities worldwide
at this point the dispute between ceno
and otec had been resolved but the two
massive security corps were just getting
started
this squabble was shaping up to be much
bigger than the corporate wars before it
both sides were escalating the conflict
every chance they got
investing heavily in weapons technology
very few parts of the world were off
limits and entire economies societies
and cultures suffered because of it
most notably in 2023 international trade
collapsed
the net also suffered from the conflict
it was rife with deadly programs and
dark areas thanks to militech and
arasaka's handiwork that watched the
internet police couldn't contain the
virtual damage either
eventually the pre-fourth corporate war
net deteriorated and died
2023 was also the same year that johnny
silverhand and solo morgan blackhand
along with a group of anarchists
raided the arasaka building at night
city to destroy arasaka's secured
database for more info on this pivotal
event in johnny's life be sure to check
out our video on johnny silverhand right
after this
this raid didn't quite go as planned and
a nuclear device was set off destroying
central night city and killing three
quarters of a million people
it's unclear who detonated the nuke some
believe it was arasaka to protect
corporate secrets
while others believe it to be militech
finally the united states government
stepped in and nationalized militech
forcing arasaka out of the united states
with militech at her back u.s president
elizabeth kress
used this as an opportunity to take full
control of the government
and reunify the united states of course
the free state of northern california
was
uninterested in reunification due to
northern california's disobedience crest
did not aid night city and its
reconstruction efforts
and this brings us to the time of the
red but we'll save that for another
video
the fourth corporate war was a wake up
call for the world although governments
and nations still existed it became
apparent that corporations were calling
the shots
allegiances didn't lie in world leaders
or countries but in arasaka or militech
and of course i'm sure we'll see more of
this bitter rivalry between militech and
arasaka in cyberpunk 2077. thank you so
much for watching this episode of
cyberpunk lore
be sure to check back every saturday for
a new episode and if there's something
you'd like us to discuss
leave it in the comments below or you
can drop me a line on twitter
see you next time
it's tough to talk about the world of
cyberpunk without spending some time on
one of the major security corporations
of the future
militech if you've been following
gamespot's cyberpunk lore series you've
probably heard us talk about the weapons
manufacturer often
you may know militech as arasaka's
number one competitor but the
corporation's history runs much deeper
than that
in 1998 the united states government
decided it was finally time to retire
the m16a2 assault rifle
marine corps officials were shipped a
handful of rifles to test out however
only three made it to the final trial
fn's sap
colts ar-17x and a firearm from a small
weapons firm called armatek lukesi
international
the sap was a cheap unreliable firearm
its only saving grace apart from being
dirt cheap was that the parts and
ammunition were compatible with the nato
alliance armaments
the ar-17x was an excellent gun with a
big price tag
although it passed the field test with
flying colors the united states
ultimately didn't think it was worth the
price
the weapon from armatech lucey
international proved to be the best of
both worlds
it was reliable and moderately priced
united states marine corps general
donald lundy a name you'll want to
remember took a liking to the armatech
lucey firearm it was his number one
choice
however due to the financial collapse at
the time the government settled on the
sap and drafted up a contract with fn
lundy unhappy with the government's
decision warned officials that putting
the sap in the hands of soldiers could
be disastrous
it turned out lundy was right thousands
of soldiers armed with the clunky sap
rifles died in south and central america
to make matters worse the european
community kicked the sap to the curb in
favor of the fnral
a fantastic weapon that was incompatible
with fn's sap
frustrated lundy left the marine corps
to work with armatech lucey
international with his connections and
experience he was brought on as the
acting ceo while the founder antonio
lucesi focused on designing and creating
weapons
thanks to lundy's connections to the
military he had no trouble securing
government contracts for armatech lucey
these contracts gave the small arms
company a leg up over the competition
as armatech lucey international expanded
lundy and lucey decided it was time to
rebrand and so
militech was born militech's first big
break was to replace all the saps the
united states military bought only a few
years ago i'm sure lundy walked into the
pentagon that day with a big old i told
you so grin on his face
militech's ronin light assault rifle
replaced fn's sap
and with that militech's popularity
skyrocketed worldwide
as militech grew and grew it swallowed
up smaller security corporations
soon competitors of all shapes and sizes
were being dismantled and absorbed by
the monstrous corporation
of course the lucrative government
contracts weren't the only thing making
militech a fortune many of their weapons
were sold and distributed to gang
members mercenaries everyday joes and
security departments at other companies
along with selling weapons and equipment
militech was known for hiring out their
private military to anyone or
anything with the money to pay for it
this includes but is not limited to
assassinations revolutions civil wars
and according to the cyberpunk 2077
world book
ethnic cleansings yikes by 2020 militech
was the biggest weapons company in the
world
selling more firearms than any of their
competitors arasaka included
however money isn't everything and lundy
knew this militech's influence in reach
didn't quite match the arasaka family
and so a not so friendly rivalry between
arasaka and militech came to be
the rivalry came to a head during the
fourth corporate war fighting between
arasaka and militech broke out all
around the world in nearly every major
country
if you'd like to know more about this
conflict check out our video on the
fourth corporate war
in the meantime here are some important
bits arasaka and militech aligned with
nautical tech companies vying for market
control early on arasaka and militech
launched a clandestine war against
each other known as the shadow war
eventually tensions bubbled over and the
two corporations kicked off a
full-fledged corporate-backed war
fighting persisted until a mysterious
pocket duke erupted in arasaka's night
city headquarters killing half a million
people in response the acting president
nationalized militech and kicked arasaka
out of the united states
on paper militech won arasaka's reach
was reigned in significantly giving
militech an opportunity to dominate the
market
however militech's victory came at the
cost of their independence
president elizabeth kress had no plans
to surrender the corporation after the
fighting had stopped
instead she used militech's strength and
resources in an attempt to reunify the
united states
if she was met with any resistance she'd
deploy militech troops
her regime wasn't entirely successful
many defected states including the free
state of northern california opposed
cress's campaign
ultimately crest slowed down on a
reunification plan as militech started
to regain its
independence however this wasn't the
last time militech got roped into a
unification war on behalf of the united
states government
let's skip ahead to 2069 recently
elected president rosalind meyers
declared war on the free states of the
united states
many states were able to avoid fighting
or remain neutral by striking deals with
the federal government of the new united
states
however the free states in need of
support looked to the mending arasaka
corporation with the devastation of the
fourth corporate war still somewhat
fresh
president myers drafted up a treaty and
the war was put to bed
currently not much is known about
militech's presence in 2077. according
to the cyberpunk 2077 world book the
united states government still
has some control over militech but not
to the same extent as it did before
i have no doubt that militech will play
a big role in 2077
but i'm curious to see how v story may
get intertwined with the massive
corporation
especially if you pick the corpo life
path if you'd like to learn more about
cyberpunk's lore check out our other
videos including one on militech's rival
arasaka
and the deadly cyborg atom smasher and
with that we'll see you next week
it wouldn't be cyberpunk without
cybernetics
enhancing your body in the cyberpunk
universe is both commonplace but
also incredibly dangerous a slippery
slope where if you deck yourself out too
much
you risk losing your humanity but this
was of little concern to one cyborg that
didn't have much humanity back when they
were human
and that's who we're talking about today
the legendary adam smasher
aka the guy who killed johnny silverhand
when it comes to these cyberpunk lore
videos we try and talk about characters
and history
we think might be relevant to the
upcoming video game
adam smasher is no exception and he'll
be making an appearance in 2077
right there so let's take a look at the
brief
but important history of adam smasher
[Music]
adam real name unknown started out as a
typical street punk
in new york city growing up in the south
bronx
adam was the leader of his neighborhood
gang the blood boys
even back then he had a nasty sadistic
streak with a dismissive attitude
towards human life
this would serve him well when he later
joined up with the
army although the army didn't see it the
same way
discharging him for quote bad conduct
and insubordination
adam would return to the big apple as a
gun for hire
or street samurai as he likes to call it
this line of work suited him until
around 2015 when one day a job went
south and adam was hit by several rpga
warheads
turning him into a bag of meat that is
not a metaphor
his friends literally shoved the chunky
remains of his body into a backpack
and dragged him back to new york and yet
adam was not fully dead a mysterious
corporation put him on life support as a
pile of flesh
only able to communicate through a tech
interface
they gave him an offer he could be saved
fully converted into a metal body
in exchange for 15 years of service to
them
adam accepted edwan's reborn as the
combat cyborg
adam smasher this mysterious employer
turned out to be none other than the
arasaka corporation
adam smasher became one of their prized
killers while still given the freedom to
work freelance
he would take on any job so long as it
fulfilled one condition
it needed to involve collateral damage
and civilian casualties
adam has long been obsessed with the
idea of being the strongest and
considered himself superior with his
metal body
adopting the mantra metal is better than
meat
his need to prove his way of life led to
a rivalry with the famous solo morgan
blackhand
morgan was the opposite of adam in
almost every way
a professional that handled delicate
situations with grace
taking his targets in alive if possible
if adam could beat morgan he could prove
that metal was in fact better than meat
however
every time adam challenged him morgan
would ignore it
eventually the fourth corporate war
kicked off a bloody conflict between
arasaka and militech adam was called in
working the front lines for arasaka all
the while waiting for his chance to take
on morgan
who just so happened to be working for
militech he finally got his wish during
the infamous attack
on the night city arasaka tower the
details of this event are
vague a mystery to the general public of
the cyberpunk universe
and books like cyberpunk red state that
no one really knows what went down
however the adventure book shock wave
not only details what happened
but lets players participate in the
event what i'm about to talk about is
canonically supposed to have happened
but it's worth keeping in mind that
cyberpunk 2077
might change some of the details looking
to end the war
militech sent several strike teams into
arasaka tower
one led by morgan and another led by
rocker boy
johnny silverhand johnny's team was
tasked with breaking into the soulkiller
lab
which housed a dangerous program that
trapped people's minds in a digital
prison leaving their body an empty shell
the plan went well but johnny's team
took a little
too long and on their way out they were
confronted by
adam smasher in a group of arasaka
soldiers
pinned down in a cramped hallway by
gunfire things were not looking good
knowing their situation was hopeless
johnny smg in hand
tried to buy his team some time by
taking on adam smasher
but against adam's metal shell there
really wasn't much johnny could do
adam pulled out his auto shotgun and
tore johnny's body
into pieces in a matter of mere seconds
the body of the
legendary rocker boy hit the ground
johnny was dead
this sacrifice gave johnny's team the
chance to escape
meanwhile morgan blackhand's team had
set up a nuclear device
inside the building and then began
extraction on the rooftop
but of course it wasn't going to be that
simple adam smasher appeared
holding the mangled remains of one of
morgan's friends while taunting him
over the death of johnny morgan couldn't
ignore adam this time and
stayed behind so the rest of his team
could escape
there on the rooftop of arasaka tower
adam smasher finally got his duel
with morgan blackhand a chance to see if
metal
was better than meet morgan's team
watched the battle from the sky
the two were still fighting each other
even as the nuclear detonation destroyed
the tower
under their feet both rivals fell into
the chaos below
their fate left unknown
but as we now know adam smasher did in
fact survive
we don't know much about what he's been
up to in the last 50 years but he still
works for arasaka and has made night
city his home
which brings us to cyberpunk 2077
though it hasn't been confirmed i think
it's safe to say he's not gonna be an
ally to protagonist v
in fact with v on the run from arasaka
after stealing their prototype chip
i'm hoping adam's role is not unlike a
cyborg version of resident evil's
nemesis
a metal monstrosity constantly hunting v
down
v also has the digital ghost of johnny
silverhand in their head
who i'm sure will want some payback for
their untimely death
perhaps we'll finally get our answer if
metal is better than meat
thank you so much for watching this
episode in our cyberpunk lore series
if you're new i highly recommend you
check out the rest of our videos
such as the one on johnny silverhand and
the fourth corporate war
both of which provide more information
on the events of the destruction of
arasaka tower
we have a new video up every saturday
leading up to cyberpunk 2077's release
so we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
av i have a job for you
a client of mine is making an arms deal
he needs
protection it could get hot
very hot the gun dealers are maelstrom
alas nothing ever transpires us plan
with them you better gear up for this
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
are you willing
yeah i'm in
if our cyberpunk law series has got you
impatiently awaiting the arrival of
cyberpunk 2077 then you are not alone to
help you pass the time we've compiled a
list of great cyberpunky books
movies and games for you to tuck into
you'll probably have guessed this one
would make the list but i highly
recommend checking out cyberpunk 2020
the dystopian tabletop game that forms
the basis for cyberpunk 2077
originally written by mike pondsmith in
1988 the tabletop rpg covers an
alternative timeline of world events
occurring between 2013
and 2045. as to the nature of those
world events
well check out our extensive lore videos
but the game consists of 10 key roles to
choose from in character creation
difficulty values to contest with net
running and
combat centered around lethality there's
no better place to start than the game's
fourth edition
cyberpunk red if you're a tabletop fan
waiting for 2077 to come out
pondsmith told dicebreaker that blade
runner and walter john williams double
hardwired
were inspirations for cyberpunk though a
number of people assumed that william
gibson's neuromancer also helped spawn
the popular rpg
pondsmith didn't actually read
neuromancer until sometime later but
that doesn't mean you shouldn't check it
out
neuromancer burning chrome and mona lisa
overdrive are known together as the
spawn trilogy gibson's novels were
published around the mid-80s and look at
a fictional future where the world is
ruled by corporations
the novel also explores the unintended
consequences of random
technology including mind machine links
the evolution of ai and a global
information space that gibson called
cyberspace the term had been used once
before but not in reference to a digital
space
gibson's works are considered to be
seminal entries in the cyberpunk genre
that is alongside philip k dick's 1968
novel do androids dream of electric
sheep which served as the narrative
basis for both blade runner films and is
responsible in large part for kicking
off the new wave science fiction
movement and subsequently the cyberpunk
sub-genre
his 1977 sci-fi novel ascana darkly was
also set in a dystopian future
california
and was the basis for richard
linklater's 2006 film of the same name
starring keanu reeves two hemispheres of
my brain
are competing yes so there's another
2077 connection for you there
if you're just not a book person no
worries there's plenty of cyberpunky
goodness to be found in more visual
mediums
look it goes without saying that you
should definitely watch the phenomenal
blade runner movies
but if you haven't already you should
also check out mad max fury road
apart from being in my opinion an almost
perfectly crafted film it effectively
captures the cyberpunk sub-genre staple
of as bruce sterling writes in the
preface to gibson's book burning chrome
a combination of low life and high tech
where technological advancements are
starkly contrasted against radical
social unrest
the locations and vibe of the original
mad max movies
also serve as a great primer for
cyberpunk 2077's badlands outside of
night city and the nomad path that kicks
off there
fury road is also worth your time
because charlie's theron is super cool
almost everyone is aussie and a dude
plays a flame throwing guitar on the
front of a speeding amp riddle truck
good movie as for what else you can
watch on the big screen check out
ghost in the shell no not that ghost in
the shelf there we go
based on the manga of the same name this
1995 anime cyberpunk film
follows cyborg public security agent
motoko kusanagi
on her mission to hunt down a hacker
called the puppet master
in 2029 the narrative touches on themes
of philosophy human identity and the
implications of technological
advancements in really fascinating ways
it's well worth a watch if you haven't
seen it or if you only called the scarjo
one
but hey maybe your ideal prep before
playing cyberpunk 2077
is just to play other great cyberpunk
video games in which case your first
stop should be blooper teams observer
the critically acclaimed psychological
horror game follows detective
daniel lazarsky portrayed by none other
than rutger hauer well i'm not a
vegetable yet
lazarsky can hack other people's minds
in order to interrogate them
and utilize augmented vision to scan
electronic devices
and biological evidence the game is set
in 2084 in krakow after a devastating
digital plague
gamespot reviewer david rayfield praised
the game's superbly detailed
environments evocative sound design and
the cyberpunk story which he called one
of the most intriguing to be found in
the genre in years
when it comes to other tech heavy gaming
franchises there's probably one that
comes to mind
first deus ex deus ex's first entry was
developed by ion storm in 2000.
the series continued over the 2000s with
invisible war
human revolution the fall and mankind
divided
the games take place within a future
earth which has devolved into a
dystopian cyberpunk society
yeah another one multiple organizations
vie for control while the world is at
war with a nano virus called the grey
death
in the middle of it all is our
protagonist nano augmented newbie agent
jc denton
aside from its cyberpunk narrative
themes the gameplay is designed to be
flexible across multiple gameplay styles
it incorporates styles across the action
role-playing
stealth and first-person shooter genres
much like cyberpunk 2077
there's an emphasis on player choice npc
relationships and player agency granted
through the game's rpg elements
if turn-based rpgs are your thing it's
worth checking out the dense and
intriguing
shadow run series based on the tabletop
game of the same name
the game takes place in a cyberpunk
fantasy world in 2054 and you play as a
shadow runner much like cyberpunk's
shadowrunners are mercs for hire
surviving on skill and
instinct and must navigate a world ruled
by mega corporations
shadowrun gained traction from its pen
and paper roots by blending the vastly
popular rpg
with the most popular sci-fi media other
honorable mentions in the video game
realm include watch dogs if what you're
really after is that hacking fix
flying wild hog cyberpunk fps hard reset
for shooter fans
and cyberpunk narrative adventure the
red strings club which should say those
who like to talk the talk in a deep
neon cyberpunk world with plenty going
on beneath the surface
let me know down in that comment box
what your favorite cyberpunk
books movies and games are and between
this and our cyberpunk lore series
we'll have you all ready to go for 2077
by the time
it releases we'll see you again soon
night city the place everyone wants to
be
the night city of cyberpunk 2077 is full
of danger and opportunity
where corporations control everything
from their luxury towers
while the gangs rule the streets it's a
place where you can carve out your
legend and stand next to the many grapes
or wind up dead in a gutter but that's
not how night city started out
it began as a simple dream by one man to
create the city of the future
a future that he never got to see
realized
so let's turn back the clock to the
founding of night city
and discover its bloody origins
[Music]
much of our information on the creation
of night city is sourced from an article
as part of the night city celebration of
its 25th
anniversary written by dr edward
michaels the dean of night city
university at the time
our story begins with one man richard
knight
during the 1980s and early 90s knight
was an ambitious businessman with an eye
for architecture and urban planning
he was a partner in the construction
firm halsey ferris and knight
which specialized in the creation of
corporate funded projects
their reliability and impressive
standards of quality made them a go-to
for many corporations
and they raked in the profits however
this status
wasn't enough for knight who eventually
grew bored of designing simple office
buildings
he was a visionary with a dream of
something
far more ambitious so in 1990
knight left halsey ferris and knight to
start his
own firm knight international there he
would begin drafting up plans for the
ideal american city one that knight
hoped would shape the future and become
a template for all cities that followed
it was around this time that the
collapse was entering full swing
it was a mass decline of economies and
societies not just in america
but around the world things were
changing quickly
and in the chaos the mega corporations
swooped in
feeling the power vacuum left by the
failing american government
many began taking control of america's
once great cities
carving out their own pieces of the
united states for themselves
but this was easier said and done as
many of these cities were in ruins and
much work needed to be done
to wrestle them under control it would
be a lot easier if a corporation could
build a city from scratch
molding it from the ground up to suit
the purposes of those that controlled it
and this is where night city of the
future came in
he needed the capital to make his dream
a reality and the mega corpse wanted a
city for themselves
it was a match made in heaven investors
flocked tonight
and by 1992 arasaka ebm
and petrochem all backed his project in
particular the backing of petrochem
ended up being of particular fortune for
knight
knight was already searching for land to
build on the central california
coastline
as it turned out petrochem owned most of
the region of del coronado bay which
sits comfortably in between
san francisco and santa barbara and was
the perfect spot
for knight's vision after acquiring the
rest of the surrounding area
construction began in 1993 on what would
be called
coronado city unfortunately for richard
knight
he would never see his dream city
completed
knight wanted coronado city to be unlike
any city built before it
he opted to use the most revolutionary
building techniques of the day
as a result this left out a lot of the
old school construction companies from
the project
many of whom were in dire financial
situations
thanks to the collapse this even
included knight's old firm
now known as halsey ferris and skiv who
were in so much financial strife that
they even made deals with the local mob
the bitterness from his old partners and
the many others who were hoping to be
contracted for the construction of
coronado city
painted a huge target on knight's back
for much of the city's construction
knight would receive resistance from
those who felt slighted by him with some
going as far as
threatening his life but knight would
not be perturbed
brushing off these threats or relying on
his corporate partners to handle them
this lasted for four years before
finally on september 20th
1998 knight's enemies got him
he was shot by an unknown gunman in his
penthouse suite and to this day
no one knows which of knight's many
enemies was responsible for his murder
the nearly completed coronado city was
renamed night city
in honor of the visionary founder
unfortunately the resulting
chaos from knight's death would cause
his dream city to never be fully
realized
the next seven years would be a
tumultuous back and forth between
knights corporate partners who had
invested
heavily in the city and the mob who had
swooped in to control most of if not all
of these street level businesses
by 2005 the corporations gave up
deciding it wasn't worth their time
and instead remained holed up in the
corporate center the heart of night city
this left the mob as the de facto rulers
and started what was later known as the
dark ages
violence became the norm and murder was
at an all-time high with thousands of
unsolved cases
the streets had become a literal war
zone
this lasted until 2009 when the
corporations
eventually chose to step in murder on
the streets was one thing but the chaos
and mob rule started to affect the one
thing that really mattered
business mega corp arasaka led a full-on
paramilitary assault with soldiers in
the streets
tanks and even flyby bombings known as
the mob war
this powerful show of force completely
decimated the mob's power and put the
corporations back in charge
the next eight years were spent finally
trying to bring the city back to a
semblance of knight's original vision
many parts of the city
especially those with major corporate
interests did become that beautiful
vision of the future that knight wanted
a place of innovation and the merging of
many cultures
a city of dreams where anyone can make
it big however
the years of chaos have forever shaped
night city and it is still a place of
dangerous street gangs
mob influence and needless violence this
would be only the beginning of night
city's
long and bloody history and by no means
the worst thing to happen to it
but that's the story for another day
thank you for watching this brief look
at the creation of night city
this is only a small part of the city's
vast history and there are many more
stories to tell
if you're interested in learning more
yourself we highly recommend you check
out cyberpunk 2020's
night city source book this book breaks
down everything about night city in the
year 2020
from its street gangs to its local
infrastructure to even its airport
the information you heard today was
sourced from this book
if you want to learn about a particular
part of the world of cyberpunk give a
suggestion in the comments
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time when we dive into the story
of one of night city's most legendary
[Music]
figures
[Music]
hello and welcome to gamespot's pre-show
for
for the night city wire episode three
i'm your host
jake decker joining me today is timur
hussein
hello everyone and jean-luc seipke
hi hi before we get on to what we're
likely gonna see
uh if you tuned in early you may have
seen a bunch of like cool cyberpunk lore
videos jean luke you and i have been
working on this do you kind of want to
let the people know what those are about
just in case they want to come back
because we got a new one
pretty much every week yeah yeah so uh
every every week me and jacob in doing
these lore videos where we basically
just like dive
into the like pre-established kind of
lauren cannon of the
cyberpunk universe the pen and paper
game's been going back for
35 years at this point so there's
actually a lot of material to work with
um
they're pretty good primers we try and
keep them relevant to stuff we think
will be
in the upcoming game so if you're
wanting to kind of know more about the
universe before you hop in and have some
backstory i highly recommend checking
them out
yeah and we should point out that like
some of that stuff we cover
could change when the game comes out but
right now what we know what we have
it's that that that's usually pretty
accurate and there's some very
surprising stuff like there was an
episode that a lot of people were
calling
spoilery even though you know it's been
out there for 30 years at this point and
you know we'll be building on it uh so
definitely recommend checking that out
but
to get into this discussion to get into
what we think is going to happen i'm
going to start out by just
reading the tweet that uh cd projekt red
sent it says join us friday september
18th 6 p.m we all know that you're here
watching
we'll take you on a tour around night
city check up on its gangs and give you
a sneak peek into the creation of the
cyberpunk 2077 original score
however they seem to have changed that
last bit about the original score
instead we have a small change lineup we
won't be talking about cyberpunk's 2077
music just yet
we will however have some cool news that
many of you request
or should i say require i don't know
what that is
i don't think any of us know what that
is uh so hopefully we find out it sounds
like it's going to be
pretty big you have a theory all right
we'll get to that
i'm excited to see what that is before
we get into that let's just talk about
the districts a little bit because there
are six districts the one district that
cd projekt red has i'd say talked about
at length at this point
is pacifica they did a video in 2018
a little after e3 i'd say i think around
august
but they released a play through of a
section
two different ways and it took place in
pacifica and they kind of gave us the
rundown of pacifica it was supposed to
be this
resort district more or less but a lot
of the funding got pulled during all the
wars and it became overrun by gang so
now it's just this
beachside rundown uh gang coast
i guess you could say so i'm super
excited to explore that
area but some of the other areas that
we're taking a look at
uh hopefully are the city center uh
watson westbrook haywood which you might
recognize if you've seen some of the
other videos
heywood is where the street kid path
begins
so if you choose that path you'll
probably get very familiar with haywood
and santa domingo uh there's a lot of
info
on those now but we don't really have
anything official from cd projekt red
but what i guess we could talk about
right now is the fact that both tomorrow
and i did get a chance to play cyberpunk
about a couple months ago now we got to
explore a lot of the world so tomorrow
i'm going to kick it over to you
having explored uh for about four or so
what do you hours what did you think of
the world give us a rundown
yeah i think we talked about this a
little bit before um
this most striking thing the two things
that really strike me is like
in terms of cd projekt's general
approach how little we've actually seen
of this city
and then the other thing is like how
dense what we have seen
has been so like on that first point i
think it's very much by design that we
haven't seen much of the city
i i felt like city project is keeping
their cards very close to their chest
with
a lot of this and the stuff that we saw
was
uh the same stuff that they should have
been showing from the very start as you
said
via gameplay demos and streams like this
and
in that time what we paid for like four
hours i didn't feel like i got a good
grasp of the city as a whole
it felt like i had barely reached the
kind of boundaries of the area that we
saw
which is kind of exciting to me because
i know that there's a whole different
flavor of city out there
for me but what i did see was incredibly
impressive at the time
uh who knows where it's at now but i
remember feeling quite overwhelmed with
everything there and wanting to pour
over the details i know that you did the
same thing where you're walking around
and like
looking intensely at vending machines
and advertising boards and that kind of
stuff
so the exciting thing about it is like
we've seen
one small slice one small district of a
larger city and there's so much to kind
of see
in that that when we do get access to
the rest of the city it's going to be
a absolute time sink to kind of really
dig into it i mean unless the rest of
the city is just like
barren and devoid which i somehow doubt
um there's going to be so much to check
out and it's so exciting i'm
really excited to check out places like
watson and and uh sorry santa domingo
um yeah it's it's it's exciting but also
like i am eager to see more of that
stuff
totally me as well because when we had
about four hours to play and i didn't
really do any story i just explored but
even then
i feel like i only really stayed in the
city center
which is what we've kind of seen before
it's kind of where a lot of those
missions take
place that we've seen as well uh and
just because
you know when i think of cyberpunk
that's kind of what i think of these
giant tall buildings neon drench skyline
all that kind of stuff so i was
mostly staying around there but one
thing i did notice was that different
areas of the map
were more dangerous and i if i remember
correctly the map did kind of indicate
this like
like for example one thing they talked
about when they showed off pacifica is
that like more people are probably going
to be ready to shoot you
when you walk into pacifica than maybe a
safer area of the town
so i'm curious to see how dangerous all
these different
areas of the city are because like i
said like
the city center when i was there like
occasionally there'd be gunfights that
would break out but usually i would kind
of start those or if i didn't i could
just kind of sit back and watch them no
one really wanted to
mess me up i didn't feel like i was
treading on anyone's turf
uh so i'm curious to see like when i go
into a more dangerous place our other
gang's gonna be like hey
you don't belong here let's fight and i
imagine that's a reason why cd projekt
red is also talking about the gangs
today
so yeah i'm super excited to see that
but another big thing that i want to see
more of that i don't think we'll see
more but i'm really curious to see how
the interiors of these different
districts change
depending on where you are like clearly
there's a lot of like lower income
houses in these different areas and
shops so i'm curious to see
how those change depending on what part
of the city you're in i don't know if
we'll see that today
because i feel like they're probably
going to be more focused on the grander
scale of these different areas but i do
hope we get to see
what the inside of these buildings look
like because you know this is cd projekt
red
uh if the witcher 3 showed us anything
even the interiors are incredibly
detailed
uh and there's lots of stories just
there alone
so i'm excited to kind of dig into that
aspect of it
uh jean-luc you didn't have a chance to
play it but you have been
helping us create all of these uh
excellent lore videos you know a lot
about the city is there something in
particular that you're excited to see
most or you hope we see
um nah i think kind of going off what
you said i i'm
i'm the thing i'm most curious about is
just like how is the world
actually what's the limits of how you
can explore it
um you know like how much how many
buildings can you go inside
uh can you get onto rooftops like i just
kind of want to know
the the limitations of their open world
from like a gameplay standpoint
is really what i'm the most curious
about like uh
can you just walk inside like a mega
corp building
at any time you want you know or like
are you
is that going to be impossible like can
can you literally just not enter or
maybe you can't enter but there are like
guards there so i
i think i'm i'm curious to see how they
limit sections of the city off like
what's what's the limitations of it all
totally yeah i want to see like to go
along with that i wonder how
accessible these higher areas of the
city are because they have said that
there's no flying vehicles at least they
said that a while ago maybe
things will change with dlc or whatever
it might be
but like i don't know a big thing i do
in gta right and i'm sure everyone did
this at one point was that hop in a
helicopter or plane
get as high as they can and just look
down and see
the city skyline given that you may not
be able to pilot these vehicles
obviously we see footage here of
the character being piloted in one of
these vehicles they're not actually
driving it
i'm curious to see uh i i don't know the
view of that that city from
high vantage points and i know that
seems small but but
i don't know it looks so pretty i want
to want to be able to see see it all
uh and to kind of go off that too the
other big thing that they plan on
talking about today are the gangs of
night city
now we i don't i'm sure some people in
the chat picked up that cyberpunk 2077
world book and it did talk about the
big gangs in night city and john luke
you actually have a video planned on
this hopefully next week
uh but the big gangs that
we're pretty sure will be in the game
are the animals the valentinos the
voodoo boys
the mox sixth street tiger claws
maelstrom scavengers race now some of
those may sound familiar because they
have talked about those before
uh but john luke while you were
researching all these gangs
you found some really wacky and out
there gangs and i figured that would be
a lot of fun to talk about
these gangs probably won't make it in
the final game at least
but well you know you never know but as
of now we kind of think they won't but
john luke do you want to kind of run us
down on some of the odd things you found
yeah i figured this would be just kind
of a fun thing to talk about
because boy is there some weird stuff in
uh the cyberpunk 2020 books that i do
hope
make it in as like dlc or something
because
uh i'm excited for the gangs that they
have in the game but
they're they're not as weird as this are
so let's just start with um
maybe how about i say the name and you
guys try and like
guess what what it is so the first one
we'll start with a relatively normal one
uh the djs
oh big big group of lucilles just
rolling around the city
just going speed
all right my guess isn't really as
exciting as that i'm just going to say
it's a
it's a bunch of djs who play a lot of
clubs but they also like to shoot each
other
and shoot people on their turf maybe
they compete over venues
and like they'll actually like take each
other out if
if someone takes one of the dj's venues
so sort of basically they they are
musicians but they
they are wannabe rocker boys who
actually have no musical talent
whatsoever
like they basically want to be johnny
silverhand but they can't
so they all decided to just get together
and
uh they just like their whole thing is
they just do like ticket scalping and
they make like fake autographs
uh but they basically are just trying to
like pretend that they're like famous
musicians when in reality they're
they're not
so they like uh they've talked about
their soundcloud a lot probably
yeah exactly they're like constantly
trying to wrap their soundcloud and
it's got like four four views on it
all right uh next one we have the
juilliard
yeah this this sounds like a it's not
like a group of like
uh i don't know if you guys would have
them here but like i guess they're like
princeton
kind of level uh students we do we'll
call them like oxford either they go to
oxford
oxford or cambridge in the uk um and
they are basically
highly educated they've paid a lot of
money to be in a school that has a
prestigious name but actually are
dumb as rocks group of people
um that's what i was going to guess too
right because isn't juilliard a music
school
i think like a very expensive music
school so that's the first thing that
popped in my mind
more more music uh influenced
another music influence gang but maybe
very preppy
i imagine something from like you know
the preppy kids and
bully scholar in the bully game that's
kind of what i'm thinking except they're
older and all cybered up and
uh maybe they're a little more deadly
than a kid who wants to box you
actually very very opposite the
juilliard is a collective of street
performers
i guess they wanted to like make
themselves sound more impressive
uh essentially they formed out of a
desire to keep uh street performers
uh safe because of how dangerous the the
streets of
night city are uh their motto is kill a
mime
go to jail
this this this just sounds like placebo
like
they're mad stuff
like they went when we get into the
later ones there were some that were
like
like the juilliard's like actually like
kind of a major gang in in the pen and
paper game but some of these were like
this is just a one-off thing that was
like there to make a joke and that was
the whole thing
but yeah the juilliard they they protect
their own
um they'll keep like machine guns hidden
in their like viola
cases uh and if you like if if you're
a street performer who isn't like you
know
under them and you try and like you know
do your shtick in their territory uh
you're gonna get a juggling club to the
kneecaps so
uh i feel like if you're going to take
out a performer you'd go for their hands
right and then they're never going to
come back because they can't play
anything yeah that's
that's a good point yeah i guess it
depends what you're doing you just get a
new
cybernetic thing
uh the next one is the bozos
this might be a little easier to guess
uh it's that
it's that new york stereotype of the guy
who shouts hey i'm walking here but like
dozens of them that would be really good
i mean i'm just gonna guess a gang of
clowns
jake has is a gang of killer clowns
oh man uh they're called the prankster
clown
uh prankster gang they originally would
uh just like drop water balloons on
people and stuff but i guess they
they eventually got more violent and
then they started like
switched degrees yeah
basically the crazy thing about them is
that
they don't it's not that they dress as
clowns is that they
used like cybernetic like biosculpting
to make themselves
into clowns so like they they gave
themselves like surgically long feet
like giant red noses they grafted like
white on their
skin so
real nasty uh i would really like this
one to be
in like a deal yeah that that sounds
like they should have been in there that
seems
that seems like a fantastic game to have
in there
if they're not in there in some regards
i think that's pretty much an oversight
on tv project red spot
this is just to interrupt you a little
bit jean-luc but this is one thing i
like really hope we see more of once the
game comes out like i understand
why cd projekt reddit isn't leading with
all this wacky stuff because
yeah it's not really what gets people
excited but now that
you know you and i have kind of been so
involved in the lore
lately like there is some absolutely
absurd and hilarious stuff that i really
hope we see more of and
and and i i kind of when i was playing
it i kind of got that impression
like a lot of the advertisements had
that sort of dark comedy
that gta 5 in particular is good at
so i think we will see more of that but
i'm really excited to see
how far it goes like even when i think
back on the witcher 3 they had
kind of examples like that like i don't
know if you remember that quest where
uh you guys the the the three witchers
geralt
uh they sneak into yen's bedroom and
dress up as sorceresses and like
basically uh randomly dialed different
different sorceresses it's wild it's
hilarious and i really hope we see some
of that humor
yeah that's that's one thing i was going
to ask you guys about like do you think
that
tonally this is going to be quite
similar in
the way it approaches uh writing in
as the witcher where predominantly the
witcher is quite serious in tone but it
has a little bit
of humor here and there and it's like a
line that will endear you to a character
whereas
but that but that's kind of dictated by
the world itself like it's kind of
messed up
and then kind of you're focused on this
one key task the entire time
do you think that there's an opportunity
here for them to have a lot more fun
with it and do you think they will do
you think that they've got the
confidence now in their comedic way to
do that because that's some of the stuff
that really took off right
with with the culture and the fandom
around the witcher people
love the memes and they love the humor
around it and do you think cd projekt
red is going into this being like let's
have some pants let's let's really dig
into that stuff
[Music]
i hope so yeah yeah i i hope so they do
because
i i think the the world of the cyberpunk
that
uh mike pondsmith created is actually
like super
hilarious it's very cynical and because
of that there's a lot of like really
good satire
in there so there's a there's the world
is primed for so much opportunity for
them to just like have some really good
like comedic moments and biting you know
commentary
like a gang of killer clowns like you
know like i
i would love to see more of that stuff
in there obviously the world can be very
serious and i think most of what they've
shown has been
relatively serious you know like the
characters kind of quip but like i think
the situations are
are pretty pretty serious i'm but i do
hope that they include a lot more of
that like comedic stuff
in in the side quests and on the
sidelines yeah
and actually this quest that we're
showing right here where these two
they're they're one person who's been
split into two bodies kind of touches on
that right
uh so so yeah i mean to go off what
you're saying tomorrow i i
i think they'll be the the single player
story will be
serious for the most part i'm sure
there'll be some funnier moments
throughout there like some levity
but i bet they're really going to go
hard on that in the side quests
and side content because you know that
that's kind of where you're more open
you can kind of
take that world and go crazy with it uh
and like jean-luc was saying there's
already a lot of satire in the the books
as is
so i feel like the potential for like
absurd funny quests are
definitely there but anyway we kind of
got off a little tangent sean luke do
you want to continue this
gang game of gangs yes absolutely uh
next up we have the
philharmonic vampires wow
that sounds amazing i love the idea that
they're standard vampires but they only
attack people who are part of an
orchestra
a philharmonic orchestra so they're like
what what do you play tuba yeah you're
getting it and then like
drain the blood from them turns him into
a vampire and the ultimate goal is to
make anyone who plays music on a high
level in an orchestra a vampire
i like the idea of them waiting in
alleys outside of like these big
philharmonic venues
and they just wait and then as the
talent leaves through the back door or
whatever they they just
they prey on them dang those sound
pretty good unfortunately not quite
right uh they're basically a prankster
gang
so i think they're just called the vamps
but people have like nicknamed them the
philharmonic vampires
they're these people that dress up in
like tuxedos and capes and they have
like vampire teeth that they've like you
know got surgically
attached to them they're also a
prankster gang they'll do stuff like
they'll like
find a convertible and then like fill it
with like different garden plants
or they made like a giant inflatable
naked doll
of the governor uh no one's really know
what
sure what their motivation is like
everyone's like are they just like
trying to make a statement are they just
trying to like have fun like no one
really knows what their deal is but
apparently they do hate minds
so they they do have a little bit of
beautiful juilliard
all right so next moving on these ones
are going to be kind of obvious what
they are
uh because of the names themselves uh
there is a specific group this is
probably my favorite type of gang
they're called poser gangs and
essentially they are gangs that model
themselves after famous people
or pop culture so this is like where you
get into like the really weird stuff
there is uh the brady bunch
which is gang that no bio sculpted
themselves to look like members of the
brady bunch
oh my god there is
uh the gilligans which is a uh
a gay gang that uh bases themselves off
characters from gilligan's island
um and there's also the there's the
kennedys
as well which is a good one i think i
know what they do i think i read about
them actually
uh there is uh
there are the the uh jack the rippers
which is a gang of serial killers let's
go this is what i'm about
get me some of that jack the ripper gang
business
my favorite like that that would be so
good as like a quest line
where you have to like catch jack the
ripper
in like 2077. that's a great idea
oh my god one of my one of my was it i
can't remember which assassin's creed it
was but there was like a serial killer
quest in it
syndicate that's it and it ultimately
didn't pay off in an amazing way like
i think that it was jack the ripper
right there it was i love the idea of
like
see that's one thing i'm really
interested in how do they transplant
modern ideas or modern kind of like uh
history into the future because i the
idea of like a futuristic person being
like oh there's this jack the ripper the
guy
i'm gonna take up that name and become
this figure or like vice versa so like
oh there's a legend of robin hood like
do they and you know that you are some
dude in the future or some just a person
in the future that's like i'm going to
outfit myself to be
a futuristic or modern day to them robin
hood i love the idea of them doing that
and i hope that they do that
well i can already take your request
right where you you're like all right
jack the rip
somebody looked like jeff jack the
ripper killed this guy
we got to figure out who did this and
then here's his hideout and you walk
into his hideout and there's just 12
jack the rippers and you're like okay
and then you have to go around
interviewing him to see which is the
murder um
i don't know i don't know if there are
any more john luke but maybe pick
one last one because there are some
other stuff i want to get into before
okay the night city wire starts because
we got about five minutes all right and
we haven't
peed on that at all i'll get through two
two more really quick actually three
okay so the one is called the bear
area rapid terror which is just a
play-off of bart
and that's the whole point of that gang
is just to make a joke about bart which
i think is hilarious
uh for those who are watching in other
in other parts of the country
or world bart is uh basically bay area's
public transportation it smells bad
that's like the big thing about it and
it's always delayed uh
there are the willow sisters which is a
bunch of young women who are
assassins for hire but they are all
sculpted to look like
famous women from history so
uh i think there's a lot of potential
there you know like hey
if you're gonna get killed might as well
get killed by 1950s marilyn monroe
not a bad way to go uh my opinion
uh my personal favorite though is the
trekkies
which are people who model themselves
after star trek
so not only do they make themselves look
like
leonard nimoy or captain picard
vulcans klingon borg
they run around in phasers their base
apparently is designed after the
starship
enterprise cd projekt red
if you're listening cbsi hit them up
work out a deal please make that a dlc
expansion
i need to see like five
leonard nimoys like beating a dude up on
the side of the street
you just see that um
so anyway yes that was a a selection of
some of the
weird gangs uh so so the last thing i do
want to talk about is they have
announced this
third announcement that we're going to
see today but they didn't say what it
was john luke you had a theory do you
want to enlighten us on what you think
that third announcement today might be
uh yeah it might not be the most like uh
shocking like crazy thing but i think
it's they're just gonna reveal the pc
specs
for the game uh because a lot of people
on their twitter have been asking for it
and they specifically said
we're gonna give you a thing that a lot
of you have been asking for so i think
it's
i think they're just gonna reveal the pc
specs and maybe show maybe show off
some of the game running at like max
settings with uh ray tracing
to more any any theories any predictions
yeah i think jean-luc
is right so i'm gonna i'm gonna go for
something a little stupider and say
another celebrity
um being announced for the game like
we've had
uh keanu um there's always been a
celebrity reveal right like keanu
am i imagining run the jewels at some
point it was a run the jewels kind of
like
musical thing right it wasn't a big
announcement it was more just like
here's the artists that are in here and
run the jewels was on there and i was
like yeah
and then yeah yesterday like um alana
pierce and now she's in the game
uh so i imagine there's gonna be another
i hope that there's another um celebrity
cameo
and i want it to be nicholas cage
take it away jake
[Music]
i would love that oh my god
uh yeah i mean i was kind of going i was
kind of in your boat tomorrow i was
thinking they just announced maybe
another
uh artist they're working with but maybe
a little more in depth about what they
do
it'd be really cool to see more about
run the jewels and what they're doing
um in this game but i could totally see
that but
i bet you you're right shawn nick i
think it is pc specs but speaking of pc
specs
we've got about two minutes left before
we do that there are a lot of platforms
to play this game on right you can play
this on pc you can play this on xbox one
you can play this on series s
or series x played on ps4 you played on
ps5 with that in mind
to more what do you plan on playing it
on and why
i think i'm gonna play on pc and like
now that i've
now that they've shown off a lot more i
feel like i can get repeat playthroughs
out of it so i'm thinking i'll start
with pc do a standard
whatever play through and then maybe
pick up another life path on
one of the other consoles um a little
bit down the line
um i feel like i need to justify my very
expensive pc purchase
as quickly as possible and that is a
good way to do it
so i'll probably start with that
uh john luke how about yourself i'm
i'm gonna try pc i have a 2070 super i'm
hoping that will
i mean it should run the game but you
know i'm hoping i can at least get
it mostly maxed out um to be able to run
i'm i'm very curious how
the next gen versions are gonna look um
i'll probably like i'll probably play it
again
on like the ps5 or xbox series x
once those versions come out although i
they haven't still said when those
updates
are coming out but i'm uh i'll probably
play it on multiple platforms
um yeah i i think like you guys i'll i'm
gonna start with pc
uh i have a 2080 ti in my pc
right now i know i part of me is like
maybe i should get the
3080 for this but i don't think i'm
gonna do that i'm just gonna stick to
the 2080 ti
uh and play through there because i
imagine it'll still look really good but
i
am very curious to see what it is going
to look like on next-gen consoles
particularly the series x
um it sounds like the playstation 5 will
have faster loading times but i just
want to see
what the most powerful next-gen console
on the market
what it will do with that game uh so
so yeah i mean i mean if you're watching
right now let us know in the chat what
you plan on
playing it on because there are a lot of
options out there
which is exciting give people lots of
options actually i guess
we got 10 seconds one more thing i
wonder if we'll see maybe a little sneak
peek at
what the dlc will be oh i think we're
done
fingers crossed maybe all right
city of dream city
hello and welcome to night city wire
episode 3
the show from us at cd projekt red where
we talk about
all things cyberpunk 2077.
in today's episode we're going to start
by taking you on a tour of night city
in a new gameplay video and have a chat
with senior level designer miles
then we're going to introduce you to the
gangs of night city
in another new gameplay video and have a
chat with matayush from our quest team
then before we finish today's episode
we're gonna give you a look at some of
the incredible
finalists in our pc case modding contest
and we have some information that uh pc
players have been waiting to hear so
let's get started
it's time to take you on a tour of night
[Music]
city
[Music]
oh my god juanita here today's news is
nova max
hi there new tonight city
it's not so bad here how we're feeling
today
because i feel amazing
the food the tie on seventh and haywood
the pierogies down by the docks our home
of pride and as always your business
is my business and this is
endless possibilities and endless lies
we are [ __ ] america and i don't know
how we're gonna fix it
the homeless population in night city
has risen by 300
crime in night city is now double the
rate than in the new united states
[Applause]
on your own you're [ __ ]
[Music]
well on that note that's it for today's
info flash sleep tight night city
the grass ain't greener anywhere else
night city what does it mean to you how
well do you know it's history
who was richard knight how many stations
are in the encart system
which city district boasts the best
burrito in town
the answers to these questions and more
can be found at the address at the
bottom of your screen
check it out and fall in love with night
city all over again
[Music]
city
well since night city is one of our
stars of this episode
there is actually quite a lot to talk
about so let's start at the beginning
how did night city come to be because
yes it exists in the world of the
tabletop
but uh how do you take that and make
what we've got now
well yeah as you can imagine making a
city that is as big
and complex as night city is is
quite the ambitious project first off we
sat down and we're really considering
what is it that we wanted to do with
night city in a way
night city is the style of cyberpunk
right it is one of its
main characters we wanted to make a city
that is
very very believable right i mean the
word immersion gets thrown around a lot
but really we wanted you to be able to
dive into it and feel like this is a
real place
and then secondly we also wanted to
provide enough variety between districts
so that exploring night city will always
be fun right there's no point
in making a city that is all all samish
and you know it doesn't really matter
where you go because
once you've been through one district
you feel like you've been through all of
them
so for that we first of started taking a
look
at the real life geography that night
city is located on
and that would be on the coast of
california knowing that night city would
be
a coastal city gave us a bit of insight
into what we would
expect from the city layout you'd expect
the port
you'd expect huge industrial areas that
would facilitate this kind of trade that
you would assume a kind a city of this
type
would have with the world and then we
went through
and actually divided the city into
several districts
six of them and some of them are based
on the original
lore we decided to give their own
characteristics in terms of
architecture their demographics the kind
of people that would live there
and also the function within the city
each of these districts in turn we
divide it into further sub-districts
which we further characterized using the
more grand
theme of the larger district this
process i think has resulted in a city
that is
feels quite alive has a lot of character
where each district
feels like its own distinct zone without
feeling separated from the
larger picture and that results in
something that allows the player to
easily navigate
even the complex concrete jungles of
night city
simply by looking around and always
having a rough idea
where you actually are but night city is
clearly so
different from anything we've ever
created with the witcher can you give us
some idea about
or some insight into just how big and
like how densely packed
night city really is yes um so
i'm not exaggerating when i'm saying
that night city is easily the most
complex thing
that i or the others have worked on the
city
is super organic right it's not like a
chessboard layout but the
the layout of the city is crazy and you
can tell that it
grew in phases right where buildings
have been built on top of each other
and i guess the mega buildings that we
have showcased are a great example of
this
um you'll actually see that they are
located on
some kind of pillar you know and then
expand outside and then up up high into
the sky and underneath it you'll have
space for other buildings this yields a
lot of interesting experiences when it
comes to exploration and that's the one
thing i'm most excited about for players
to experience
we've been saying that our exploration
is super vertical right but what this
really means
is that it changes the way you explore
the city
compared to our previous games you won't
be able to
easily set out on a target in the
distance right you won't be able to say
oh there's a castle on a hill over there
i'll try to get there and then you'll be
lost on the way
but here it's much more intimate much
more moment to moment
you might be roaming the cities and um
get a call by your fixer who informs you
about a job nearby that you might be
able to do right
or you find an alleyway and you walk
down one of the many many alleyways that
the city has to offer and it's always a
surprise you don't know if you might
stumble upon
some gangers hanging out that are up to
no good sometimes
and these are the moments that i often
get surprised with you even stumble upon
the odd elevator that is meant to
connect parts of the
you know different layers of the city
and it's quite astonishing sometimes to
see
where you come out when you enter one of
these and you know find that oh this is
actually how it connects to the world
that's crazy and now i'm here and now i
know
there's a shortcut that i can take and
again
this all serves to really enhance this
sense of wonder that we all come to love
from open world games and the whole city
is built to cater to that
i mean you guys have really brought
night city to life and i really want to
make a point of that it is a living
breathing city
so as a level designer can you give us
some insight into those little touches
that you guys have made because
i hear you guys even been placing
rubbish by hand
oh yes um we've been placing quite a bit
of rubbish and that's certainly one of
the more glorious parts of being a level
designer or environment artist where you
get to litter
the streets that you've spent time
building with the garbage but it's
details such as this that
we find really important to make the
city feel alive and also
we take great pride in the process of
making this right
we have a lot of fun actually placing
lot of what we call mini stories right
these are little encounters um that you
can find when you simply walk
along the streets of course we have huge
quests right
side quests we have lots of side
activities that you can do
but it always is nice to just kind of
stop down for a minute and take a look
at your surroundings
and that we have so lovingly created and
try to see if there maybe isn't
something that you can be a little
detective for
now one other thing that i think is
really really cool is also the fact that
we have
um actually named every single street in
the city
so not only will npcs be able to
communicate their locations or the
locations
they want you to visit by sort of
referring to the street names
but also you will be able to talk to
your friends about it in that way right
have you been to
poplar street in japan town for example
um
and i think this is a small detail but
the philosophy that we have with these
kind of things is that you know many
many small things
contribute to the sum of it which is
hopefully then you being able to explore
a city that you feel is truly alive and
that you haven't been
experiencing before uh well miles thank
you so much for giving us
your insight i suppose when the game
launches you could be an official night
city tour guide instead right
i might be yeah you know if this game
death thing doesn't work out for me i
might
might retire and become a tour guide in
night city
don't forget that if you are tuning in
late or if you just
want to watch anything again we will be
uploading everything to our channels
soon now from the 6th street to the
valentinos
it's time to introduce you to the gangs
of
night city
you know how things work in night city
stronger survive but that's how things
stand
you're either somebody where you fizzle
out into nothing
then see in a city that lets you get by
with our buddies
be very careful my friend we are all so
far from home
which gang's the city's biggest and
baddest according to the ncpd
scavs hold the body count title or
maelstrom depending on the season
one time a maelstrom ganger killed a
young kid right in front of my eyes
for shits and giggles crumbs sucking
psychos
and who the [ __ ] are you to say what can
and can't be i'm gonna
introduce you to our meat grinder
about time we had some fun big belts
you'll never forget
never i hate these borg [ __ ]
she's a gang like any other right i'll
take the valentinos
they follow god and the santa madre
honor means something to him
how'd you meet jackie we started out
together in the valentinos
no in the [ __ ] bible book club i
gotta give style points to the
valentinos
they have a punishment for every
occasion
[Music]
quick shout out to everyone in haywood
and santo domingo
lately the valentinos and sixth street
have had a bigger bone
i've dealt with sixth street before we
do the run they'll transfer the cred
come on let's go before sixth street
shows up
[Music]
vomit lofty patriotic [ __ ] all day
time to bring on the future any idea how
many attacks from behind the black wall
we neutralized if the voodoo boys breach
the black wall we'll all be [ __ ]
voodoo boys urban myth i thought
just net runners spooking each other you
know i heard a few things about you
voodoo boys best runners in town you do
not steal from the voodoo boys
i see you always for them pacifica is
just haiti 2.0 their own island cut off
from the rest of the city
this is our turf our home until last
week
the animals crawled in animals are the
craziest [ __ ]
gang in the city
animals aren't the play here are they
they're hired muscles someone else
needed them
i [ __ ] you over you [ __ ] the gang
over somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [ __ ] the corp see how this
works now
my husband's new westbrook very high in
the tiger class
they did what made the best eddies sword
sex and black market
see a lot of tigers they run this place
know what else they do well
break the needs of people who ask
questions we gotta do something shut the
[ __ ] up the tigers will kill us
come on baby tiger claws killed one girl
too many
so people took matters into their own
hands
spoken ballistic girls pimps
outcasts the whole freak show it's how
the mocks got started
us have each other's back we look out
for one another
you're looking for some company tonight
how'd you hook up with the mocks
i thought susie and the gang could
really change something in this city
moxes and nomads don't seem so different
both seem to yammer a lot about
community
solidarity tell me about the badlands
not much going on out here oh contraire
this is an ecosystem nomads grafton shiv
corporations and drifters they form a
complete hole
remove one part the delicate balance
topples
here in the aldocaldos it all stays in
the family
classic dilemma what comes first family
or the outside world
this family will go to hell and back
everyone in this city lives in their own
bubble
and either you fly high or sink into
quicksand
[Music]
matajus thank you so much for joining us
i have
personally been really excited to give
people a closer look at the gangs
we've shown a little bit on twitter but
their styles are so distinct
yes i enjoyed them a lot as well in our
game i think they're very cool
but let's start them with the kind of
role that they play because gangs really
do play a prominent role in night city
correct
yes definitely the gangs they rule the
streets of night city you know they have
the newest cyberware they have the
newest weaponry
and they are really a power that
everyone needs to take into account when
they are
thinking of operating in night city you
will encounter them as you explore the
city of course but also as you complete
main quests side quests
different jobs for the for the fixers
sometimes you might even get hired
by them but then i suppose everybody's
thinking then
can you join a gang well v is a merc
and mercs of night city are this unique
distinct group
that stick mostly to themselves right
and they get jobs from
variety of factions they can get jobs
from corporations they can get jobs from
gangs they can get job from
different kind of like influential
clients because of this
nobody will ever trust a merck to be one
of them
right and the gangs are no exception
here they are looking only for like
people that they know will be loyal to
them right and that they will fight for
their cause
all of the time not just some of the
times when it's profitable to them
so because of this we will mostly stick
to the afterlife and the after
our life are this group of mercs this
legendary group of mercenaries in night
city they get the best jobs they get the
most money
the best clients and so on so if you
want to become
a legend in night city you are going to
the afterlife
so we've obviously mentioned distinct
style then so does that mean there are
kind of special gang
themed weapons and items and clothing
for players to
find and use yes definitely there are
different vehicles that you can drive
for example there are cars there are
motorbikes
um then of course there are different
pieces of clothing
uh themed after gangs there are weapons
and so on so yeah definitely there are
things to look forward to
i suppose as somebody who's spent as
much time as you have
kind of getting to know the gangs i have
to ask which is your favorite and
why so i would have to say probably
maelstrom
simply because they have this unique
distinct feel
and this weird aesthetic about them so
the idea about maelstrom is
they are people who want to cross the
boundary between
the machine and human right they are
changing so much of their body with
cyberware that they
no longer look human really on top of
that they are also very unpredictable
it's very difficult to say what they
will do
at any point when you meet them uh at
one moment they can be shaking hands
with you and at the other moment
you know they will pull gano again out
on you and they bring in this element of
chaos into the game which i
really enjoy personally oh matty thank
you so much for joining us
it's always interesting to learn what uh
your favorite gang is i think it kind of
tells me a little bit about you
oh does it what does it say about me
well we'll talk about that later but for
now before we wrap up today's
episode we asked people to show us their
creativity
and design a pc case mod cyberpunk style
our panel of judges selected five
finalists and we teamed them up with
professional case models to bring their
concept
to reality
these five amazing designs will be
fighting for the main prize
and alienware aurora pc along with other
awesome gaming peripherals
brought to you by our partners alienware
nvidia
and steelseries let's see the mods
absolutely next level honestly kind of
terrifying
exactly the type of thing i would expect
to find at a trade show
it really looks like it could have come
straight out of the game
[Music]
to watch the full pc case modding video
and to get more information about when
the winning design will be available on
charity auction
stay tuned to our social media channels
looking at those pc case mods it reminds
me that we do have
one more thing to reveal if you're going
to be playing cyberpunk 2077 on pc when
it launches this november
we do have some specs to share that i
think some of you have been waiting for
the minimum system requirements for
cyberpunk are a windows 7
or 10 pc an intel core i5
3570k or amd fx
8310 eight gigs of ram and an nvidia
geforce
gtx 780 or an amd radeon rx470
in the storage department the game will
take up roughly 70 gigs of space
and although it will run off a hdd we do
recommend
an ssd as for the recommended specs
you're in the green if you're rocking
windows 10
an intel core i7 4790
or amd ryzen 3 3200g
12 gigs of ram and an nvidia geforce
gtx 1060 or amd radeon
r9 fury thank you so much for joining us
for episode 3
of night city wire don't forget that if
you've missed anything
or if you just want to watch again we
will be uploading everything
to our channels shortly and we will be
back soon with
episode 4.
and we're back that was a lot of
information i i
definitely like that one a lot more than
uh episode two
talked a lot about the gangs which was
awesome it was cool seeing those gangs
in detail
and then also the world which i think
for me that trailer stole the show
because we were just talking about in
the pre-show that
we want to see more of that comedy that
that maybe not lighter side but that
funnier side of cyberpunk and i feel
like we got to see a lot of that
uh john luke why don't you take it first
what was what was your favorite thing
what were some of the highlights
i think my highlight was just like the
the different tv bits they kept cutting
back to
i think like getting to see like their
the the like media and the culture of
like the world i think like
says a lot about it so like uh you know
just like
getting getting a sense of like this is
what people watch this is the attitude
that people have
i hope that it's like metal gear solid 4
where i can just like watch
tv for like a you know like half an hour
and then like watch a bunch like
you know 2077 uh news or whatever it is
um well i'm sure we'll get into a little
bit more but they
uh at the end of the trailer they they
had a link to
uh nightcity.love which is a real
website you can go visit
um that has uh really well done and has
like a lot of like that details and
has like ads for the for the mayor and
and like little spam ads popping up
um i absolutely love this stuff
uh rig what what is this easy beef
they're like worms in like a petri dish
like what is that
dude i am so excited like i am gonna
just spend
so much of my time just walking around
looking at the little signs like
reading all the ads like seeing what
people are like lining up for like they
i'm so happy that they have clearly just
put a lot of detail into like
just people walking around and and like
i i think
i'm gonna spend a significant chunk of
this game like not even doing quests
yeah totally i mean i think to your
point like one of my
favorite things about a lot of these
open world games is just being able to
walk around and check things out look at
all the signs look at like
red dead redemption 2 is a game where
like i love the story but my favorite
part of that game is just getting on my
horse riding around just taking in the
scenery
seeing what people are up to and it
seems like that's definitely going to be
here in this
and like not only and like oh i can just
check out and see what people are doing
but like
you were saying like i wonder if i can
just go back to my
v's apartment or whatever and just like
turn on the tv and watch some of these
absurd shows they showed off because
like
i i don't know just all that detail is
so cool uh but anyway to jump off that
tomorrow what was the highlight
you saw or highlight yeah
i i mean like it's gonna sound like a
lot of what you guys just said but
i think one of the really interesting
things in this game about you know
people transforming the way they are and
the way they
look um to exist in this new world is
the way that
cd projekt red is kind of giving us a
way to
kind of be in this world and transform
our own world
to exist in this one which is like
really fascinating and that's what this
this this uh um trailer i think was
important about showing like we've seen
so much of the game focused on gangs and
v trying to do this mission and you know
how you interact with them that it was
good to have a
a a kind of showcase of what happens if
you just step back and
just want to exist in this world without
any of that and
like jean-luc said the stuff around the
advertisements and the tv stuff and the
world itself was really really
fascinating i think there's a lot to
you know it's kind of like the way gta
does it right where you you get
like obsessed with brands in there and
you you trying to dig into like the
history behind them and what they what
tone they
add to the world and it seems like
there's so much in here to really
unpack and this is this is basically
your law right like all of these
advertising billboards this website that
they just put out it's the law for you
to dig into
and like create stories about which is
exactly what we do like the thing that
you guys do on on your like weekly uh
series is
no different from you know what avarti
video would do for a dark souls or
someone else would do for
like you know binding with isaac or
whatever game that there is to final
fantasy
14 to get obsessed about but this is the
really fascinating stuff and
i think a lot of people will now be
actually motivated to dig into that
stuff people have already had that
excitement around oh i can't wait to
really immerse yourself and this was the
first time they were like
you can start doing that now in a
meaningful way by going to this website
and
look at this trailer we've got so much
for you to dig into and also when you
play the game
you can just live in this world and one
that's super saying to they're super
dangerous when
escapism is so important right now to
present this whole fleshed out really
deep world
like i have a feeling like a lot of
people are just going to go into the
world of cyberpunk and we might not see
them again for a really long time
it might be me it might be me uh so
after they shut off that trailer they
did do an interview with miles toss who
is one of the lead level designers and
he talked about
the layout in the world and one thing
that he mentioned that stood up to me
was saying the layout of the city is
crazy and more vertical
now if you're here for the pre-show we
talked about hoping that
this world would be more vertical and
that we could you know climb up to some
of the higher skyscrapers and
and get a view of the world so it sounds
like that will be the case at least to
some extent um
but the other thing he talked about
saying that the layout of the city is
crazy which really stood out to me
because
when i did demo this game a couple
months ago
one thing i noticed was that like it
really felt like
like it was complex it felt very complex
while i was exploring this world and
trying to figure out like okay this is
my location
up there this is where i need to get up
there now i have to like
follow this like intricate set of set of
stairways in order to get to where i'm
trying
to go and then i'd get up there and
there'd be like a whole little shopping
center that was completely obscured
by all these giant buildings that i just
walked into that's like crowded and
there's a bunch of people walking around
and
chatting and whatnot so so that kind of
stood out to me because that's exactly
how i felt
um another thing john luke that you
brought up uh
as miles was talking about how there
won't be or
all the streets will be named uh
and you brought up like can you play
this game without a hud can you get
around this city without having a little
mini map in the corner
did you kind of want to explore that a
little bit
yeah i mean that is i think me and and
you too as
well jake i know are like really
interested in the idea of like playing
games without huds
i i'm i love the idea of a game where
you can just
more like in tune where to go for
for like quests and stuff like that like
breath of the wild i think is like you
know
the the best video game example of that
it was something i tried to do with the
witcher but
it isn't perfect like a couple of times
you could do it but sometimes it's like
i don't really know where to go it's all
forest um but with this
by them saying like every street has a
name you know like there are so many
like distinct signs and buildings i i
really wonder if
uh if they designed it in such a way
where you know a
quest giver could say like i need you to
go down sixth street over here and you
could be like oh i know where that is
i know where 6th street is and you could
just kind of eventually
you know by exploring the city so much
you know the city
uh by you know the back of your hand and
you could just naturally know
exactly like oh i know where that bar is
i know on the exact street and the exact
corner that is
um i i am definitely going to be trying
that out
yeah and even to expand on that one
thing that i'm curious about is
like like cybernetic implants obviously
play a big role i wonder
how that is tied to your hud for
instance like i i'm
i like you said i'm someone who likes to
turn off all the hud elements that i
don't need that i don't think i need
and roll like that but like in a game
where there's
actually like an in-game explanation for
these huds i'm a little more lenient so
like i wonder if i can
almost like customize my hud through uh
through cybernetics you know like i
could go to a store and be like okay i
want an improved
map because i want to be able to see
where enemies are but i don't
necessarily need
like an armor display or something like
that
so so i'm super curious to see how games
kind of get you
think more about ui and how ui kind of
interweaves with design as in in a story
way as opposed to just like
here is the here is the player's sort of
like
screen door that is in front of the game
that says all these stuff that your
character doesn't know but
you know because you're playing you have
to know
um yeah it's kind of like that um that
near automata thing
like that game does it amazingly well
where you know the chips that you put
into yourself
are affecting how you see the world and
i'd love to like you guys said see
some more of that like you're i love the
idea of having someone who plays
just trying to jam every modification
that they can
into themselves but by the end of the
game their screen is just littered with
crap that you know no
other people might not have and it's
just like telling them useless
information and bombarding them
like that would be amazing whereas
someone who like really is trying to
stay pure and
and keep it has like a few different
mods so you could be like oh i'm kind of
someone who you know really struggles
with like pathfinding or like um
you know finding my way through the city
to where i need to so i'm gonna get this
one mod that you know
puts that dead space style you know uh
objective marker on the ground that i
can follow i love the idea of that and i
hope they do stuff with um
mods that genuinely change the way you
see the world and the information you
output and get back from it that would
be so cool
totally and then one other thing i do
want to talk about uh is that they did
mention that they are
placing all the rubbish in the world by
hand
which sounds absurd but
just imagine that job to just like go
through and
place rubbish throughout the world of
cyberpunk because i imagine there's a
lot
uh but moving on we also got a look at
the gangs we saw a
trailer of all of the big gangs i wonder
if there'll be more like maybe
some of the ones that john luke talked
about in the pre-show but
having seen that i just want to get into
uh what your guys's favorite gangs are
based on what we saw
john luke do you want to start sure yeah
uh i
i was really happy they showed uh quite
a bit of each of them
he did uh i got to point out jackie when
talking about the maelstrom gang he
referred to them as borg's which means
that star trek does exist in the
cyberpunk universe
so they can put the trekkies in make it
happen um
yeah i mean i think mike i kind of
mentioned it when we were watching my
favorite gang
is the mocks because they are a group of
um
uh like sex workers who uh like
basically protect other sex workers like
sexual minorities they're
essentially like probably the the most
like neutral good of all the gangs um
from like kind of what we've seen so i i
think like i like their
pink neon light aesthetic so like that
personally is the is the most appealing
to me
and i imagine um they will potentially
be
uh more allies in in the in the story
for v um but i mean i i really
appreciate overall just like
the variety of of every gang like they
all feel
very distinct um the the tiger claws are
another one i'm very interested in
because they're kind of based on like
the yakuza and they got these like kind
of like um
luminescent like neon tattoos and and i
think like their vibe just looks
really slick totally
timor how about you yeah john luke
mentioned my favorite gang is the
tiger claws they're the ones i'm super
interested in um
you know hanging out in japan town but
they kind of strike me as like very
influenced by
you know i think they have an obsession
with like motorcycles and vehicles and
that kind of stuff
um like uh yeah so a
big akira vibes for me um so
and obviously that's a franchise or a
series i love
um so i love the idea of taking some of
that you know mike pom smith is
obviously drawing influence from a lot
of different places
in creating the world of uh cyberpunk
and so we see the project red and i love
that the fact that they've got
a gang set up to be you know influenced
by
akira and various other japanese kind of
like media
um so yeah excited to see that and
they're like super territorial and
they're very combat focused and
i love the idea of this like group of
basically futuristic
uh samurai style kind of uh folks
um hanging out and you know sticking to
their turf but if you get anywhere near
them
like it's gonna pop off so i love that
idea
yeah the the tiger claws look awesome i
was gonna say like
a shout out it's not my favorite but i
like sixth street because it just seems
like a bunch of like
hillbillies with guns out in the middle
of nowhere like
i don't know doing their thing and i
don't know i feel like there's a lot
there to make some like funny quest
interactions and whatnot
um but i think my favorite was the
maelstrom based on what we saw
because it seemed like a lot of that
sort of like cybernetic body horror
stuff like that guy with his like
head caved in but like has this weird
vision or site i don't know thing up
there
which looks super rad and something that
i want to see
explored in the game is cyber psychosis
which is something in the lore
that's basically if you cyber yourself
up too much you kind of like lose your
humanity and go a little bit crazy
uh so i'm super curious to see what they
do with that and i think where they'll
probably explore that is with the
maelstrom because they seem to be
the most uh cybered up of
all of these gangs they seem to have
like a total disregard of what
what humanity is just like seeing all
those characters they even kind of
touched on it right how they
they are very like i i don't know they
they have a lot of mood swings like one
second you could be talking to them
chatting them the next second they could
pull out their gun
and and it could ensue a fire fight uh
so i'm super curious to see what they do
with them
uh one thing or another thing that they
didn't talk about they ended it with the
pc specs
uh i don't know if there's a whole lot
for us to talk about on that other than
that they're there which is nice because
i know a lot of people are curious about
that
we could say that john luke you were
right
whoo that was right
[Laughter]
that was in fact the last announcement
uh but they did say
there is going to be an episode 4 of
night city wire i thought this was going
to be the last one because on their
website they had three slots for the
night city wire
but i'm sure they've updated that by now
uh so before we close out
what do you guys hope to see in episode
4 of this night city wire and maybe when
do you think it'll be because this game
is
pretty close um i reckon i reckon it's
gonna be
the the stuff that they had to cut from
this one right the music stuff
um so in all likelihood they'll it'll
probably
be soon maybe in like two two weeks or
so um
maybe three weeks uh and then and then
it will be focused on
the musical uh part of uh cyberpunk 27
so
luke how about you yeah maybe i i
definitely agree with him
they'll probably touch on the music
since they didn't cover it this time
uh i'm trying to think of like what else
they could possibly cover because at
this point like we so we know so much
about the game and it's so close
i think maybe they could do just like
one more
maybe like character refresher so they
could like quickly talk about v a little
bit they could talk about jackie maybe
they could talk a little bit more about
johnny silverhand maybe just like kind
of one more thing to just remind
everyone like these are some of the
major characters that are going to show
up in the game
um just to kind of give everyone the
full picture and
honestly at that point like i don't need
to see anymore
i'm ready like i think they've shown
enough of the game to really get a sense
of like what this game is going to be
like yeah i mean to be honest
i felt that way after like the first
showing that first 40 minute long demo i
was like
i don't need to see anymore i'm sold uh
that being said it is nice to get more
information and have events like this
where we get
a little bit more of a peek uh but yeah
i think you i think the music for sure
is something they'll talk about
considering it got cut but i really hope
i've said it i think every single
pre-show we've done for these now but i
really hope
we see more on the relationship side of
this game
because that is something they talked
about early on about how
uh the relationships will be very
in-depth and i'm super curious to see
how those
end up just because usually they end up
being a little awkward
even though you know sometimes they
can't be good like mass effect i know a
lot of people really enjoyed that aspect
of mass effect but i'm curious to see
if they bring anything new to the table
or any new nuances
and how i guess broad that system
will be because that sounds like it
sounds huge
um but with that said before we close
out any last minute things you guys want
to
call out talk about from that or maybe
in the future or
i don't know just something you're
excited about
i really want to see more of the uh
music stuff so i'm excited for the next
um
episode especially like i'm a big
hip-hop guy so
i want to see if they've got more than
just like to run the jewel stuff and
see if they've reached out to any other
artist to kind of get them in um
yeah i love i love the flavor that music
can add to this game
so on top of you know the hip-hop stuff
i want to see who else they've got
knocking about in there i bet you
there's some names beyond just grimes
and
run the jewels yeah it did seem like in
those trailers they did
give you a sneak peek at some of the
music coming as well
um and some of that sounded pretty good
jean-luc how about you
i'll take the opportunity to plug uh our
upcoming lore video where we're gonna
actually talk about
the gangs that are gonna be in the uh
game basically more details from
what you saw uh a lot of those gangs
actually are from the original
uh 2020 pen and paper game so like
they've kind of evolved over time so
a lot more details that you can look
forward to at gamespot.com
cool and i think that was that's about
it we'll see you next time for the next
cyberpunk city or night city wire
uh but until then like john luke was
saying be sure to check out all of our
lore videos there's a lot of them at
this point there's a lot more coming
uh and you know as cyberpunk gets closer
to release we're gonna have a
ton more coverage so stay tuned
[Music]
you